- one young bill burr paper tiger coming
out tonight on net exciting are you
pumped yes I am I'm very excited I think
more just to see you know just to people
see how good it looks
it was Mike binder directed it and uh
you know I I just I don't know I just
had this idea for how a special I wanted
it to look and none of it really had to
do with other like necessarily comedy
specialist more like rock concerts that
I saw and that's saying it's all like
super jumpy and stuff but just sort of
like I don't know that's weird how the
way they shot [ __ ] back in the day where
they held shots longer so it sucked you
in so you kind of felt not necessarily
that you were there but the presence of
being there and I really have a
disbelief that if you [ __ ] go edit
really quick quick quick quick quick
it's like flipping through the channels
and each time like your brain resets
yeah and like when you go to a show
you're just sitting there looking at the
band or looking at the comedian like
that it's not like I'm here now I'm in
the balcony now I'm behind you now I'm
up here and all that so we tried to make
sure like the pacing of it I explained
it to him he was just like I get it he's
a comic so yeah that certainly helps
yeah so the way he did it I hope that
people see that as opposed to the [ __ ]
that they normally do like how can I get
offended well they definitely get
offended it's a it's a sport now to get
offended by comedy seems like people get
excited to be offended I know a lot of
the questions I've gotten out from
people non comedians that have been
about you know well within the light of
Dave special is this like once you guys
are mad at Sebastien like a week ago
now it's Dave were they mad at him for
the mvh one thing no they weren't one
person got mad and wrote something and
then everybody oh yeah oh yeah I didn't
realize I didn't like that I don't like
that what was it I didn't hear a peep
out of that did you hear what your to
start it back up for me try to get him
get him all going again it was just like
I don't know why he did that anyway I
was like those things are never fun
you're you're you're basically you know
you're the host of what's a commercial
for a bunch of bands
it's just he's a great comic he sells
out Madison Square Garden and he did a
great job - yeah he did a great job
somebody was talking about four times in
two nights yeah which is crazy
turned over Madison Square Garden like a
comedy club yeah like he's doing an
improv show Saturday
come see me square it said uh oh yeah
Madison Square Park in the round there
was no other way 18,000 people yeah
18 times well I say cookie could have
done giant stadium he could have he
really could have but it's like why why
bother why bother doing the vh1 Music
Awards it's just it's not a good venue
for comedy it's not a good like people
see him it's not you know why because
Eddie did it Chris did it I'm gonna talk
too much to keep this [ __ ] thing
going and it's like Al it's a legendary
old-school stand-up gig you know you
know it's one Music Awards now is MTV
was it MTV Music Awards oh they're all
the same to me
does vh1 have their own Music Awards
they don't get me I might've else I
would own you know what I'm talking
about
doesn't making CDs sellin CDs after the
show I know I still remember that MTV
was cooler than vh1 does your via Jaguar
have a CD player no didn't like my car
doesn't have one either all right my
Tesla doesn't know a [ __ ] let's try and
do the math is he subtly insulting me
no you got a cassette tape anymore I'm a
VCR in the trunk somewhere along the
line they just stopped making them well
that's the thing you know what and I was
in New York all summer and all those all
those the up-and-coming rappers are like
trying to hand you a CD it's like what
am I gonna do with that they still have
CDs well then they do something then
they just click on this to scan this and
it goes to like a Vimeo page and then
I'm like because this guy in my phone
now like what just happened does he have
my contacts yes so I just kind of steer
clear to them
I can't weirded out by those little Q
stand things is that what they call them
was a cute Q what was it QR code QR code
I get weirded out by those things
because your camera goes on it and then
boom it opens up a website I'm like what
has happened
here I'll tell you what's a weird one is
they have home security systems now
where I was reading an ad for this on my
podcast and I was thinking like
afterwards like like a lot of times home
I guess
I know alarm goes off because your
window blows open and then everybody
[ __ ] shows up and it's like oh sorry
the window blew open this actually has
video cameras so they can confirm that
somebody is in your house but then I'm
thinking like well what's to stop them
from just turn that on and start
watching your life like a show
nothing like a hey they're fighting
again well for sure if there's a stream
it's possible for someone to do that for
sure if there's a stream no no and the
contract it says we would never do that
oh okay it's not like some people don't
do that doorbell camera from ring has
partnered with 400 police forces
extending surveillance concerns yeah
yeah yeah I mean as long as they're just
using it to catch the bad guys which is
gonna be what they're saying but there's
gotta be somebody somebody has their
dick in their hand right now get through
that doorbell it's an act and the way
people get obsessed like and then then
you're jerking off just to the woman
walking up to the door to go into her
house and it's not enough man I can see
what's up I got to see what's behind the
door calls up hey would you be
interested in furthering your security
no I think the doorbells enough
interesting you say that we just had a
case the other day where unfortunately
she thought it was enough and it wasn't
really and then tells him that now he's
watching her eating corn flakes it's a
slow creep into your life how much time
before it's everywhere before everyone
can see everyone everywhere yeah I don't
know well what's weird is younger people
that have a much different idea of
privacy yeah because they [ __ ] has kind
of been out there I would not want to be
young right now they have a real tough
time we're through when I was younger
when I got my ass kicked it was over
it wasn't video documentation for the
rest of my life this is the kid from
Rocky Point he's all grown up now and
you're trying to get laid in a bar like
20 years later you like gas that
happened I was
I was eight sorry I was just thinking of
that I watched this kid tried to throw a
triangle up in a street fight and the
guy slammed him on his head and punched
him unconscious and kept punching him
while he was out and the kid just
climbed off of him and walked towards
his friends and everybody's like oh oh
this guy's lying on the ground pulling
up his arms like probably experiencing
severe brain damage and I'm thinking
what if that was my son
you know what does your son you want
some some guys slam I'm on his head and
then as he's unconscious punched him
five six seven times in the face yeah
that's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] that's why I
stopped fighting that's why yeah I wanna
hurt anybody no no I didn't want to be
that guy I was like baby fat tough until
like [ __ ] sixth grade and then I sort
of leaned out and I was like I better
get funny and then that's when people
started to learn how to fight and there
was blood and [ __ ] and I remember there
was his dude I think I talked to all
this stuff I got up the kid got off the
bus he was [ __ ] jack the other kid
was kind of baby Huey big guy but the
other kid got off the bus first he just
jumped him and then just sat on his
chest and it was it was like oh those
[ __ ] fights the kid didn't come to
school for a week
they came back to my time he came back
to school most of the swelling come down
but I almost looked like he was a cousin
it wasn't him yeah and I was just like
yeah I'm not I don't I don't want that
to happen to me so that's one of the
darkest things that ever heard anybody
say about a fight khabib never going off
said about Conor McGregor he was I want
to change his face yeah see there's
people out there like that that are like
yeah there's this that okay I should
stop now is missing and you don't want
to be underneath all of that they just
kept getting worse the older I got that
sound of somebody's head hitting the
floor the worst and Sam WorldStarHipHop
videos where well the worst one I ever
saw was this guy was drunk and he was
talking [ __ ] and one guy knocked him out
and then when he's out called lying down
everybody took shots at him I mean
everybody in the street people were
kicking him in the hand were running up
to him and kicking him like a soccer
ball punched him in the face I mean like
10 15 people doing it just running up to
a boom
running up punching them oh yeah
horrific how did we get on this I don't
know I got a great special code yeah
you're telling me special is nothing to
do with brain damage or random acts of
violence why'd you decide to do in
England um cuz I'm a Zeppelin fan and it
really it was about doing it at that I
didn't I just wanted to perform at that
venue Royal Albert Hall yeah so then I
performed there and I had a great time
although I was in my head for a long
time like during the show I was like I'm
standing where Robert Plant was standing
and John Bonham's drums were [ __ ]
right there and I really had a hard time
because while you were doing stand-up
yeah how many shows you do I just did I
just did the one I was in June of last
year
wow you only film one show no no no no
that that's the first time I did it so
then you know some of my reps came over
I was just like wow this place is
amazing I mean it was it was incredible
and we just started talking just going
thinking maybe could shoot especially I
was I don't know I was like huh it's my
[ __ ] gonna work over here would be
different you each special I try to make
it be a little different a different
vibe you know Southern crowd northern
crowd West Coast east coast or whatever
so we just kept talking about it and
then I talked to binder about it and it
all just became about me and him smoking
a cigar in London I was like I [ __ ] it
let's do it and then the whole way up I
was questioning going did I [ __ ] up was
this [ __ ] stupid I should have just
shot it in the States and then I'd be
like no no not was a good idea it's good
idea wait a minute what I would have
what if I don't [ __ ] and just you
know which probably ended up being a
good thing for it but um you know I did
a run of dates leading up to it before I
shot over there and I kind of knew what
was gonna work and I knew what wasn't
gonna work and then you know people who
are showing up there listening to your
podcast so they get like the references
and stuff because I was talking to
somebody go surprise you know they got a
lot of those references it's like well
that's a specific crowd coming to see me
if I did all of those jokes in front of
just a random London crowd I think of
people you know right the [ __ ] this
guy talking about where'd you do gigs
before you did London when you did a run
at gigs did you do him in
yeah I did a Liverpool Manchester
Glasgow I can't remember and then I did
one other one beginning with a B I
forget you know it was just literally
Bam Bam Bam and I got sick when I was in
Liverpool I don't know what happened
they ate something before I got there or
whatever and I had like this stomach
virus I had it the night too when I was
shooting it I was like getting over it
and so that was like this always and I
was thinking is there always something
or might just that age that there always
is something but I just don't notice
until the night there's cameras here you
know what I mean when everything's
heightened yeah oh my god [ __ ] threw
my back out never [ __ ] fails special
bah bah bah bah it's just like well I
throw my back out a couple times a year
except I'm just not shooting that night
so I don't give a [ __ ] and I just joke
about it so why don't I just do that
when I go to do it so how many shows did
you film we did two and it wasn't the
same night either so it's kind of weird
rather than make bam bam
so you're warmed up I can't even get
going both times so and like most times
it was the set that I liked better it
was probably I think the second night so
most of its from the second night and
then there's just a couple just because
it went a little too long I just I just
wanted to get in kick the [ __ ] out of
him and get out leave him wanting more
the old school thing so there was just a
couple I didn't we just took just a
couple things just to kind of splice one
section out of there and splice the
things and then get it going so how many
seats I don't I don't remember
I don't think please I don't remember
but I do know the night of the special
like I I did this thing I was making fun
of that whole support the troops sing
and everything and what had happened was
it wasn't working
and it was killing the whole time like
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me finally
go to record this [ __ ] I'm above bla bla
and it turned out that some terrorist
group had made a bunch of [ __ ]
threats or something that day oh yeah
and nobody told me
oh you know well don't tell him I don't
get any [ __ ] hits now if they're
going like why isn't this working
I suddenly not funny
well like it didn't work but it there
was just this thing hanging in the
[ __ ] air had I known that I would
have addressed it and then it would have
been fine so we just we just spliced
that little you know six seven minutes
out of there that's a great bit though I
love that it is but I recorded at
Madison Square Garden for just like a
double vinyl I'm gonna do oh real yeah
yeah I'm into all those old school rock
pieces like I lose my ass I'm gonna lose
my shirt on it but it has that bit on it
didn't you do that before like at Radio
City or somewhere you did another album
in the past was at Radio City I did one
at a Carnegie Hall and then the last
time I did Madison Square Garden I
didn't explain it to them correctly that
I was trying to record to do an album
there and they just took the audio from
the board so I'm just like super loud
and it sounds like I'm trying to eat
people lesson learned
Arius yeah so I like doing that like
nerd out comedy [ __ ] like I love all
that stuff like I just saw Tarantino for
the second time I cells once upon a time
in America and I went down to his
theater that he bought that Beverly
cinema and they had all this cool merch
from the movie like you know buttons and
posters and t-shirts and [ __ ] I didn't
buy anything cuz I'm trying not the Hat
because then I get sentimental when I
can't [ __ ] throw it out it's like
hoarding yeah yeah
does your wife get mad at you for [ __ ]
like that what hoarders she go why did
you bring this home did you not the one
who says that oh I'm the one who goes
like okay now what are we throwing out
not throwing out because then it ends up
in the [ __ ] ocean where are you gonna
bring that where someone can actually
use it yeah so now like whenever I do
whenever I do like comedy festivals or
anything and they have that whole merch
bag I just say I don't want it yeah good
for you yeah well we got a phone charger
[ __ ] yeah that's not gonna work in a
couple years
cuz I'll have a new phone and then I
just have that thing do people send you
a lot of [ __ ] like no does the podcast
you don't get t-shirts or stuff like
that
occasionally but I kind of put it out
there like I just need you to listen
that's enough I don't need you to
because then what something 1/2 what
sucks is when people really take time to
make something right and now it's like I
can't leave
this behind and it's always big and
awkward and I kind of [ __ ] am I gonna
get that my back and then you show up at
the airport with some big stupid thing
with your face on it like the [ __ ] is
with this guy that's always weird with
someone's wears their own shirt when a
comic or a musician or something yeah I
had a guy who I really like zubi he was
here the other day rapper from England
he had his own shirt and his own hat on
it wasn't such a great guy I would have
given him a hard time
I just you have quite a few listeners so
he's getting a free free advertisement
out of it I would imagine
I don't know well he was getting
advertisement of the whole podcast I
would imagine right you don't have to I
guess me everybody's got their own fine
way of doing [ __ ] so I don't know but
I've been having fun I got to tell you I
was so envious of you earlier this year
because you put out your killer special
and just watching you getting to do my
favorite thing you know dump the [ __ ]
I'm sick of and try like the new stuff
so that's where I am in my act and I you
know I follow you on all the stuff and I
was well I think around May or something
June you said alright it's ready to go
and I was doing an acting gig and I
couldn't get the sets that I wanted I
was like [ __ ] man that's what I want by
getting it I got to get going on this
ship because people watching I gotta
[ __ ] follow you sometimes down the
store which is never fun well we're
doing gigs together this Thursday we're
doing the improv and the store I'm very
excited about that
yeah I've been doing a lot of these kids
my lightsaber goes up about this far
right now where my act is I go to turn
it on things how old is your act now
like the actor working with um I look I
can I can go down I can I can murder
with 20 and then the rest of it it gets
a little we get a little lost at sea and
a piece of plywood you know yeah it is
it with people haven't paid to come see
you so what I will do is I'll stay
adrift a little bit and then I'll just
do [ __ ] from my special but now as of
you know today at midnight I feel I
won't be able to do it so so now that's
gone so then you still be able to do the
troops bit because it's all in there
I won't do it because I did it already
and it's coming out on something and I
also feel like most places I'm gonna go
to I already did it in that city right
and I have this paranoia
that this exact same people show up have
never had fans come and sit in the front
row two nights in a row and you see them
I've had people back-to-back shows an
eight and then a 10:30 and then I
sitting there it's just like and they're
just sitting there the rabbits already
in the Hat it's a body double they they
know everywhere where it's going Teddy
Bergeron bit he's wearing a wire
he's wearing a wire Santa Clauses it
really is wearing a wire
how good was that guy people don't know
he was one of the greatest of all time
he really was I saw him when I was an
open mic and I almost quit he keep one
up on an open mic night oh yeah and Bill
McDonald was those his name yeah that's
funny those early on guys can make you
want to quit oh my god yeah he was so
good he was so polished I felt like such
a slob no the thing about him a shoe was
it was effortless and he made it look
effortless
it was just effortless he just went uh
John Pinette was a guy I saw well I was
just like it didn't make me want to quit
but I was just like I was just like what
the [ __ ] was that yeah he went up on a
Tuesday at Nick's yes and it was like
[ __ ] you know there was like maybe 30
people this place held 400 people is
just like a lull it was like when I
started was the 80s hangover and just
stand up was dead there was like 30
people as a bunch of you know bitter
comics ago this place used to be packed
he'd be lying around the block you
should quit all these [ __ ] so [ __ ]
Pinet just dropped by rest his soul he
just dropped by and he went up and did
12 minutes and got a Stella jet it
wasn't oh yeah John Pinette thank you
for stopping by you're famous it was he
[ __ ] murdered I think that was the
first time he was kind of it was that
era when he was doing that you go now
buff a bit yes where it just keeps every
time you think it got to the height
of how funny it could be it went to
another level and then another another
the only time I ever saw a guy maybe I
got like Regan or something with a just
had that he just repeat that thing I I
was doing a tour with Norton Attell and
Jim Breuer and Jim Breuer had a bit
never cursed about his dad shouldn't
spend his dad [ __ ] his pants and the
thing he kept going back to other than
you go now was the like he was gonna
puke
dude I remember the first time I saw him
do that I was in Atlantic City and I was
standing there was a wall behind me and
I slowed I was laughing so hard I
started sliding down the wall I was
holding my stomach going [ __ ] what is
that bro is an animal he's one of the
most underrated comedians of all time
the worst I ever ate it coming up ever
following Jim Breuer in like 91 Boston
no no we were at a comedy loft I think
in Nanuet New York and I should not have
been headlining I've been doing comedy I
Bobby Kelly about those gigs those gigs
are you shouldn't have been hand are you
worried I've been doing comedy maybe
three years four years maybe maybe four
I just wasn't ready no way but my
manager was good and he got me a gig as
a headliner he's just decent Milo and
Breuer was meddling mmm-hmm we were fine
I was fine until late show Saturday
night when I tell you he went up like
just like a man possessed and he used to
have this bit about coming home drunk
and his mother was a demon you know do
you remember the bit no but I know his
talent so he's already doing drunken and
that demon voice he's gonna do it so his
facial expressions and and he just
caught it he just caught it where it was
like I mean he had murdered all week he
had murdered all week but I'd gotten by
like I did not have as good as that as
him all week but I got by it was good
good enough no not embarrassing Saturday
night Late Show let me on fire
championship round let me on fire I
walked on stage early I'll supposed to
45 minutes I think I did 35 it was death
35 of death nervous feeling like an
[ __ ] wedding
haribol terrible turn like shaking it
took me forever to recover it took me
weeks weeks I had one one time I just
did Vegas whenever I go there I always
go by the the Trump right that's what is
yeah yeah I got I was contracted to be
the headliner and I got bumped down to
the middle act oh I got demoted who was
the middle I don't remember but he was
great and it was Frank del Pizzo was the
was the host and he was like a seasoned
headliner the other guy was a seasoned
headliner and I just said I don't know
what that was some young guy they were
giving a [ __ ] shot to so I went out
there this is like the late 90s and I
had my shiny black button-down I'm
playing Vegas shirt you know and my
manager at the time gave me [ __ ] about
the shirt on you're gonna wear that okay
yes [ __ ] Vegas you wear whatever you
want so I walked into the club and it
was just where the Trop was then it was
like an older crowd because they hadn't
redone it or whatever so it was just
like they're dying off crowd so dude I
went up there and I I did sort of okay I
just did okay but they both had better
sets to me and then that was the Tuesday
or the other Wednesday and then the
Wednesday I came up and by then I
started to have another not good set and
then I got in my head like like I'm not
gonna be able make these people laugh
and I remember just seeing like there
was just this lady back towards the
kitchen and like her old lady you know
that hair that looks like it's flammable
funny it was just backlit and that's all
I could see dude and I just went in and
out of like like bombing and so then was
at Thursday morning comes I'm flying my
girlfriend out at the time so she could
see my big headlining set in Vegas
my name is out on this sign right and I
remember she caught I don't remember her
name but she called me up she's just
like bailet so-and-so from the the Trop
how you doing I'm like good good she
goes yes so how do you think it's going
I said she said I was like you know
things go pretty gang of crows little
old last night a little bit she just
goes yeah you know I don't I don't think
it's happening and you know I
I think it'd be better if you just
midweek he's still gonna pay the same
money she was real that was the worst
part she was really nice about it and uh
then I had to go down there that night
my girlfriend was coming in the next
night I had to go down there and uh you
know I just never coming in and Frank
was looking at me and I he was sort of
looking at me like how is he gonna
handle this and I just was this I I
guess I sucker what am I just real and
then they were they were both they would
never mean to me they would never mean
to me a both really really cool guys and
we had like a great weekend but then my
girlfriend came down and it was just
like I to explain to her why there was
another person going and me did it go
better with you as a middle oh yeah you
know you know what it was yeah it went
better and then by the end of the
weekend I figured it out but I was never
funnier than the headliner or Frank I
just wasn't I just I wasn't seasoned I
didn't know how to do it and it was my
first weekend in Vegas and is that true
I think it was it was my first weekend
in Vegas because then in the next few
years I would middle at The Improv at
Harris so that was the thing you know
it's funny was I was really depressed
about it and my girlfriend didn't care
you know we still here we gonna have a
good time whatever and then I was almost
getting like upset with her that she
didn't understand who instead of being
like oh wow you're really cool that the
reason you came out here was because you
just wanted to hang with me I was too
young and angry and self-involved yeah
it's hard when your girl sees you bomb -
well fortunately she didn't see that she
just saw me middle-middle that's not bad
it could have been worse yeah she could
have been there while the whole thing
went down I guess I don't know one of
the worst bombings in my life I was
working with jb smooth who's [ __ ]
phenomenal and i was supposed to be the
headliner but it was a weird college gig
in the middle of nowhere in Jersey and
it was hard to get to and there was no
GPS back then so you had to follow
directions right remember those give you
a piece of paper yeah they'd call you
okay you gonna take a right out here and
the left there and then you take the one
on one
so I said about the person doing the bad
directions where they would go okay and
then you're gonna see a farmhouse on the
right it has a red door and there's cows
out front they all right am I gonna take
it right there no you're gonna keep
going and they just kept bringing up
[ __ ] that you were gonna see it's just
like fine you just like just tell me the
[ __ ] thing that I'm gonna see when I
turn is it grassy hill and there's
there's there's a scarecrow white right
now you're gonna keep going it was just
like all right sorry no words noise so I
miraculously got there on time but JB
did not and so they go well we're gonna
wait for Jay because he's not here yet
so I go okay they go well we have a
lounge you can go sit there and watch TV
so I watch TV and it's a special a new
special on the Malibu fires so this is
probably like whatever 93 or something
like that some gigantic fires now as
before 93 it's like 91 92 and there was
a fireman the fireman was weeping
because he had saved his house but his
neighbor lost his house and he had saved
up all his money to help build this
house this guy you know it was like his
life's work to build his house but he
was devastated because he was a fireman
and his neighbors lost their house this
guy's weeping he's weeping about his
house and then they had this [ __ ] kid
calling out for his dog they couldn't
find the dog they lost the dog and they
were hoping the dog got away to safety
so there's kids walking around rusty
rusty just walking on the street rusty
rusty then lady opens up the door
JB's not here so we're gonna have you go
on first I'm like oh no so I went
onstage thinking of that kid calling for
the dog and the fireman crying and I
just ate [ __ ] I mean I just went I had
nothing all right there was nothing to
do an hour
no I wound up doing I want to do I think
I'm supposed to be 45 minutes I wound up
doing the 45 minutes and I mean I ate
[ __ ] I did not I did not get any laughs
I don't remember I mean I was depressed
I remember thinking I could never do
this again
I did it one other time too though I
could never do this again it's [ __ ]
terrible to make matters worse jb
eventually got there halfway into my
said he goes on after me and
and murders I mean murdered nuke the
room flattened it these kids were so
tired of me there was and I was like
look I [ __ ] up i watch this to pray
and they were so excited to see me
because you know they have those college
conference things where you go like
nafta or whatever it is and you go is
that what it's called what are those
things called NACA those no you just
maybe forget it you know then a yeah so
there's something college campuses
whatever the [ __ ] it is he's never
forgot that my life - you just said
NAFTA after it's over now I'll never
remember it someone screaming it there's
a comic out there screaming it into
their their Kaka NACA that's right so um
I did NACA and murdered I mean murdered
they told me look you can do it slow
infrastructures forms Hut sets they they
said look mmm I remember having a
conversation my agent she said look I
know you're you're not clean but if
you're clean you can get a lot of gigs
you can get a lot of gigs that was the
big I mean it's just people are eating
[ __ ] they were eating shared the
conference because all these comics were
like nervous and I said you know I'm
doing my club set I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not a clean comic I can't do
this I've already done this before I
tried and I went up and I did all sex
material and [ __ ] murders so these
kids were so excited to see me and I got
there and just a [ __ ]
oh no they and they they were blunt way
to this guy oh wow he's gonna be huge
someday oh my god H it so hard I'm just
picturing you doing all your sex
material compress bah-bah me ever not
just bombing like banging a girl
doggystyle day old but it's this is how
you do it
not this scoliosis thing I know that bit
would [ __ ] murder not that night I
remember that and then every chick in
the room wanted to [ __ ] you and then I
would go on stage with my orange afro
Hey
anybody hi yeah mmm yeah that I ate yet
and one other time I ate [ __ ] real bad I
was headlining as well this is like just
this one is not nearly as bad as the
other to eat shits the Jim Breuer one
was devastating but in all fairness it
was good for me because it changed my
act it made me realize like you got to
respect people's [ __ ] attention span
you can't go up there thinking about
yourself and trying you gonna respect
these people paid money work hard but
you got to be ready and you can't
[ __ ] take headliner gigs when you're
not ready to headline yeah I remember I
did the same place a year and a half
later and [ __ ] murdered and I was so
happy I was so the guy said Wow you
[ __ ] got better am I thank you thank
you saying all this one out the other
time where I ate [ __ ] I acted a
conspiracy theory book about JFK then
I've [ __ ] loved this was called best
evidence by David liftin this buddy of
mine who's in a band to hold the pale
horse that's great rating before you go
up we kind of came here well I read this
and I was like oh my god they shot JFK
it's the [ __ ] the government he said
the casket was empty the [ __ ] they
did they changed the autopsy I had all
this [ __ ] in my head and I was you know
25 so I was by some guy who wasn't there
well I was written by a very credible
guy who was actually paid he was at
count n't and he was they hired he was
so inside they let him look in the
casket they said listen I'm just gonna
show this to you there's nobody in here
yeah we did it the hired mouth shut to
go over the Warren Commission report but
they never expected anybody to read the
entire report cuz they're poorly [ __ ]
nine hundred volumes or some [ __ ] just
an incredible amount of pages but this
guy went over it with a fine-tooth comb
and he's like this whole thing was
horseshit like the whole Warren
Commission report was horseshit they
concocted all these different things so
I went on stage with this this thing in
my head like oh my god there's evil
people running the government they
killed Kennedy and I'm the guy who's
gonna save everybody so I ate [ __ ] on
Thursday night and and then I you know
they were very they're a little uneasy
with me because they knew I was like I
was a re was doing well at
like I was a comic they were looking
forward to seeing right and then the
next night I apologize I said listen I
[ __ ] up yesterday I read this
conspiracy theory book it'll never
happen again
and I went up and killed the next night
but I knew I knew I'd [ __ ] up I knew
it was a mistake I was just listening to
ac/dc only time you as funny I listen to
them on the way over here then I'll
never get over cuz I got the new tool
album and it's [ __ ] unbelievable and
but I always end up just I can't get out
of that [ __ ] orbit I just ended up
going back well it's such good [ __ ] man
it's such good when out when I need a
really pick-me-up I listened a whole lot
of Rosie oh yeah yeah that'll get you
how [ __ ] good is Dean Del Rey's voice
how [ __ ] good is his voice when he
was singing that oh yeah [ __ ] that you
should have heard it you should have
heard it my Instagram
dude his voice is [ __ ] phenomenal
yeah wasn't it a whole lot of Rosie that
he was singing yeah he sang a whole
bunch of [ __ ]
he sang all his [ __ ] voice is
incredible isn't he going through some
weird of it back [ __ ] right now
does he have some bulging disk issues
yeah I think it's it's left over for
other March man [ __ ] these matches from
the that's how easily like accidents you
should just do heroin [ __ ] these cigars
okay Joe the from his motorcycle
accident well that's a serious flame you
got going there buddy oh yeah something
like that it's kind of his story so I'm
not really sure I know I was joking with
him I go you realize yes unbolting
distancing left from his motorcycle
accident oh so you realize half of that
is the motorcycle and the other half is
you being a frontman of a [ __ ] rock
band banging your head for [ __ ] two
and a half decades he laughs yeah I
worked with them this weekend out in
Vegas he [ __ ] killed but I noticed
I'm trying to sit up and kind of be a
little straight but he's definitely
getting through it and we hung out or
next day and we saw Elton John cuz he's
on the farewell toast [ __ ] unreal was
it good three hours no opener starts
with a hit play
it was like closing bits for three hours
and then watching how he moves he stays
pretty much at the piano but watching
how he moves its [ __ ] and then they show
like the old highlights where he was
like in these [ __ ] platform shoes
just slamming the piano and pushing
himself up like you know almost bending
over backwards coming down he do like
three four times in a [ __ ] row look
at him there yeah oh there you go yeah
and like when he walked look you just
I just respected the [ __ ] out of him
when I saw him walking looking like an
NFL running back going this [ __ ] guy
now he realized people paid money oh you
mean looking like a current NFL running
back no no no I want him like like when
you see those guys uh
not the guy was getting elected into the
Hall of Fame the guys who've been in the
Hall of Fame for ten years when they
come walking up to hug the other guy and
all this [ __ ] kind of settled off yeah
but like those piano rotates and
everything smoke fire
oh yeah just jam and on that things like
wow I actually missed that part I was at
the Steak and Shake or something
speaking of tool and rock related
injuries
you know Maynard when he's on stage he
stomps his foot on the ground like
stomps like you know he's always like
stomped when he sings
well he's a jujitsu guy and he was
having a hard time like working on
certain moves he's like my [ __ ] hip
it's like something wrong with my hip
mm-hmm one of how many get a hip
replacement from stomping on the ground
he stuck his hip out do you know how
Kogan would he back when we doing the
Opie anthe show he came in I was like I
thought this guy was like six seven yeah
yeah and his buddy he was like six four
in his arms hung down to his knees
though yeah and he ended up saying that
because of that finishing move II did
what he would leap up in the air and
just land on his ass night after night
after night week after week he lost
three inches in height yeah all these
discs yeah I got so compacted yeah all
your discs deteriorate from from
wrestling like almost every wrestler I
know including me I have a bunch of
disks they're all [ __ ] up but they're
there okay enough or I can get by and I
use machines like if there's a machine
called a reverse hyper or it sort of
decompresses your spine I do all this
spinal decompression [ __ ] actually and I
get Regina keen once a year which is
like this it's like an advanced form of
platelet-rich plasma actually got it
today I've got like little band-aids I'm
gonna [ __ ] outlive all of us listen
I've got the cash to pay for this [ __ ] I
[ __ ] take everything what do you got
what do you got that works your body's
like a restomod it's like you look at
him and he's 50 51 but underneath it's
20 19 he's got a little ipod jacket is
[ __ ] chest people don't even know
what we're talking about we take an old
car like my Corvette that's not out
there but my Corvette that's what it is
so I got 1965 on the outside but the
inside is all mm it's all the suspension
is all brand-new modern chassis I like
it the underneath I don't like the
interior also to look right like me too
yeah it has to look like like yeah
speaking of that that's another reason
why I had to go see the that Tarantino
movie twice effect for that was [ __ ]
amazing was I was so busy looking at all
the cars and it has one of my favorite
cars of all [ __ ] time I'm not a speed
guy I like cruising and there's a 67
Cadillac Eldorado in the color that I
want and that's one of the meanest
looking [ __ ] cars what color was it
in the movie it's like this I don't know
what I got yellow or something Dean
asked me he's like what's the factory
color you know he knows it you know he
knows all of it but he knows it right
it's like a it's like this no no that
that's that's that's uh that's a hard
car doesn't he have a soft top in there
no no you know what I'm thinking of I'm
not sure Sharon Tate's friends just look
up Cadillac Eldorado because they're
just gonna have yet the car Brad Pitt
was driving through lien this is
Leonardo DiCaprio's best work oh it's
amazing and it [ __ ] you got a seat again
he's a man I'm actually gonna see it for
a third time to catch all this [ __ ] and
I don't want to ruin it for anybody but
you why I'm not gonna say anything put
so Leonardo DiCaprio has a different one
than Brad Pitt does well Brad Pitt's
character
driving Leo's car Oh is the yellow one
that he's in that not sure what he's
well no no but the the Eldorado which I
think is this 67 is it when a Sharon
Tate's friends pulls up to our house in
it oh okay okay - scene yeah those old
Cadillacs are [ __ ] phenomenal good
luck get one of those into the comedy
store parking lot though there's no room
for anything else I would like to do
yeah just have the under everything be
brand new underneath and then just yeah
I just driving the [ __ ] right lane
smoked a cigar you can get it done I
know no I can't but I that's a slippery
slope oh I'm already down it I know you
are hey you want a warehouse that's the
slippery slope so I have my old truck
and like I like going fast if I was like
at a track like Dean went out and drove
a bunch of fast cars out in Vegas and he
was just like a posted until he goes was
shown how [ __ ] cool was and it's like
the next time that that time I went out
there I took my lovely wife with me so
we were doing you know couples [ __ ] I
was gonna be like hey thanks for coming
to Vegas I'm gonna go drive some fast
cars they have a CVS that's all lit up
the Vegas style you should check that
out howdy you know like where the [ __ ]
would that get me but uh that was a good
trip for us too by the way a good family
Vegas trip yeah it's a good thing to do
as a married person to just sort of like
my mother-in-law watched our kid and we
came out there and it's fun it's
hilarious that's nice like there yes and
we know but we immediately go right back
to like me my wife I've like ridiculous
chemistry laughs and like just totally
on the same wavelength and it just
[ __ ] resets and I'm learning now like
you got it just with the day-to-day and
deal and you know but you guys do date
nights do you do a lot of date nights
yeah probably not enough it's like
everything do you work out yeah not
enough to eat well yeah not enough and
then your relationship becomes like the
same way and I've I finally gotten out
of my stupid [ __ ] you know died on
every he'll [ __ ] argue everything you
know I'm getting out of that and I'm
starting to understand you know how to
how to do it the you not in competition
with your wife that's what you got to
understand yeah yeah but then there's
also that she's also humans
everything she says isn't right you just
have to pick yeah you got a pic cuz I'm
not gonna be that guy where's your happy
wife happy life all those guys are get
done I watch whatever TV she wants to
watch I'm envious of them are you those
because they have the smoothest [ __ ]
life never lose their house they just
like to stay like a [ __ ] you know as
big doorman buildings where I got a
package for you mister like you become
that in the relationship you should just
say we're like the Bell cap and
something like that yes those lifer
doors yeah yeah they're like in a union
neutered yeah I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with being a doorman
before everybody in a [ __ ] uniform
gives me [ __ ] yeah they're like you
become like that in the thing but no we
came back and last night you know before
we went to bed my wife was like glowing
she was like I had the best time and we
barely did anything we just [ __ ] hung
out laughing you know appreciate that a
lot more ones in kids because you
realize like this is a rare moment this
is hard to do it's hard to get away yeah
I mean yeah it's hard to connect while
someone's going I wore popsicle I wanna
read popsicles yeah well with my kids
they're older so they they fight with
each other that's mine let me you can
even use it it's mine
yeah no you can't you yeah and
everything is just you know they're
separated by two years - so the little
one is fierce cuz she always feels like
she's getting the short end of the stick
from the older one right so she [ __ ]
she stands her ground she draws a line
in the sand and you know she's ready to
throw now it's awesome she doesn't know
how to apply it yet but that's gonna
serve her well she's not taking any [ __ ]
I'll tell you that but she's a super
sweetheart my daughter's at that age you
know where I used to joke bit my act
that like I always loved toddlers
because they're like these little drunk
people like they have no social graces
you like literally in the middle of a
conversation they come start talking
real loud you can't understand them yeah
that's that's kind of where we're at but
uh you know in like the best way ever
that is
one of the one of the advantages of
being an older debt is everybody who
[ __ ] up being a dad you know that look
on their face like that goes by so fast
man I'm telling you cherish every
[ __ ] they sit there like the ghost of
Christmas past
yeah scaring the [ __ ] out of you in a
good way I guess the cool thing when
they get older is you do stuff with them
you take them places and like go on
vacations together and hang out with
them all day long 24 hours a day
multiple days in a row like we every
summer and we go to somewhere in Europe
or somewhere with the Thailand last year
Thailand and we did too I'm too
intimidated to go there Thailand yeah
it's amazing people are so nice yeah
it's so nice it's hot it's [ __ ] they
got weird bugs and my little one got lit
up by bugs man like she she had a virgin
too something that bit her and her whole
hand was swollen it was a real freak out
moment that [ __ ] we're in Thailand and
something's medically going wrong here
Wow there's also weird - it's like their
culture is very odd doing that had a
happy ending
yeah yeah it did say yeah we cuz we're
at a resort to be a place of emotion
yeah so toothpaste the other day no we
got some medicine and they applied a
topical medicine to it and actually went
down within you know by the next day was
okay but it was an issue yeah they're
sorry well Thailand's hot you know it's
muggy and rode elephants we did the
whole thing hang out hung out in the
jungle was wild what sounds oh yeah yeah
I'm ever seeing that yeah yeah yeah yeah
elephants are cool man
they're weird it's a weird little
relationship you have these animals
they're so gentle like as long as they
know that you are a kind person and
you're taking care of them
you walk because like the people that
run this at they've run an elephant
rescue thing it's really kind of know
about that that I'm the kind person know
what an elephant is just like you know
what I don't really feel like yanking
these logs up and down this [ __ ] hill
I don't understand why I'm doing this
ship this guy seems pretty cool no not
like that you don't do anything with
them other than feed them and you get to
ride them but like and people are a
little bummed out about riding them and
I'm like I don't really recommend riding
them look my family wanted to ride them
and you know a lot of these people ride
but the whole thing is a rescue
thing they take these animals that are
in circuses and all these different sort
of mistreated animals and they take care
of them and they let them live in a wild
environment they roam free they just
feed them so that elephants stay by but
they go they go off on their own too and
then they come back but they have these
big piles of sugarcane and so they're
eating the sugarcane they're eating
they'll just stop while you while you're
walking with them and they just rip a
[ __ ] tree out of its roots to start
eating it you realize how goddamn strong
they aren't they are [ __ ]
preposterous least wrong I wish I I wish
that we viewed them more as like
roommates
yeah than like ours so we we did be de
plan it up a little smarter yeah I guess
I shut my phone up I could show you I
found this picture on Instagram of this
tiger and the [ __ ] thing is what
looked like its legs but it looks like
it's doing dips the list of [ __ ]
muscles it doesn't even look real like
like like that thing exists on this
planet and was just like was just
walking around free that you could just
bump into it I understand you know like
when people first came out here and they
eradicated that's along the lines of it
I mean look at that [ __ ] how many
pull-ups Joe do you need to do to [ __ ]
it look like that [ __ ] oh my God look at
the [ __ ] muscles you must have seen
that one do you ever see that one where
they were [ __ ] with that tiger in
that dude was on the elephant yeah and
this thing took off like Jordan in the
dunking contest just and every time he
did I reached its apex it kept going up
like [ __ ] Zion there on Duke yeah and
it barely grazed the guy's arm when it
clawed him toward park you know yeah the
guy like he had nerve damage and his
[ __ ] arm didn't work oh yeah for sure
yeah I mean there's a great video recent
video like two weeks ago of these guys
on a motorcycle in India and they're
riding horses chasing them and the tiger
almost get some it's full clip chasing I
actually looked how fast they can run
and I'm surprised because the guy wasn't
like a scooter or something they can go
like 40 miles an hour I think what
[ __ ] him up was the surface that he
started out riding on right if he was
more in his element they get money like
a dog in a kitchen gets a little [ __ ]
the tiger didn't slide yeah a little bit
yeah on the concrete right yeah yeah
well maybe just the sound of the engine
was just like that doesn't sound tasty
well it's one of the we're rare places
on earth where Tigers hunt people
there's there's a history of them
hunting people they hunt or they come
upon another ally they hunt them there's
an area called the Sunderbans and the
Sunderbans Tigers over the last 200
years have killed more than 300 thousand
people there they actively you know
people believe it or not it's a quick
death oh yeah I already know what I
would ever do if I ever came in contact
with the tiger just do this that's
exactly what I would give them the neck
and make some defensive move like our
offensive moves just to get it go right
towards it oh there's no sector yo you
UFC guys are all like I would rather get
[ __ ] choked out then knocked out it's
the same thing you just go to sleep
yeah you just sleep I mean it probably
hurts for a second and then it's over
Oh hurts for a second then as you start
to go I think the last thing that's as
bad is the smell of the tiger all the
breath the breath big day me rotten meat
breath oh just affect oh they don't
really bathe do I swim don't they okay
yeah I can swim fast this is how fast
you smell amazing did you see those two
poor women who they were gonna take a
[ __ ] hike through the rain forest and
decided to go themselves gone what
happened they found their clothes
where was this which rainforest I I
don't know so that was right in your app
right up your [ __ ] alley isn't - I
was surprised it wasn't on your
Instagram like that's that's like that's
a Rogen [ __ ] right there
that's a bummer man people get confused
and they don't understand you you're a
moving thing and you don't move quick
and they're they're all about eating
moving things if you're moving they're
trying to eat you if you if you're by
yourself they're gonna eat well it's
amazing that wherever we started on this
planet that our brain was able to cover
for the fact of how [ __ ] slow we are
we're slower than squirrels like
everything everything is like
think fast out there except sloths
sloths I know but they like in that but
that's their job
to get eaten yeah yeah like jalapeno
poppers you might [ __ ] that you just
order you want to go say [ __ ] it let's
get that slop yeah yeah this is what you
go after the real thing you try to eat
one of my favorite videos was watching
harpy eagles kill sloths they swoop in
and snatch them they're like the largest
Eagles in South America you get a
zipline tour in Costa Rica
yeah and the guy knew how to make the
noise of the this this [ __ ]
ridiculous wingspan bird that doesn't
really exist in that area anymore but
they're just in their DNA for them to
freak out because it's three toed sloth
and he imitated it and the [ __ ] thing
just just kind of looked around a little
bit it's like dude you just gave that
thing a mini [ __ ] heart attack
we did a zipline that was one mile you
get on it you you zip across for one
mile as I'm sliding on this thing with
my family by the way I'm thinking one
last thing they check this who's
checking this was a great thoughts the
[ __ ] ladder was rusted and then lat
ratchet bolted so they had like straps
were they ratcheted where the ladder had
rusted and then they just grabbed a hold
of strap and like clamped down on it and
[ __ ] tree and we're climbing up this
and it's like a little watch out there
that parts rusted through like what
that's rusted through and then you get
to the top and they latch you up to this
thing and I'm telling you you're above
the rain forest and it's just yeah and
you go for like [ __ ] ten minutes just
how high those two we were we were just
in the [ __ ] we were just in the very
tippity-top up we've been Costa Rica so
we weren't like in the [ __ ] and I just
remember like the thing where we were
doing you know the little I guess
platform that you went up to was so
[ __ ] high off the ground and it was a
third up to tree yeah like when we were
looking up at the three-toed sloth that
was over there it was like another four
five hundred feet it seemed it was
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous
you know nature man nature man there's a
[ __ ] great story recently of a guy
he's a musician and he was recording
sounds of nature and he
I'll sleep and a bear ate him so it's
recording of him getting eaten while
he's recording sounds of danger bears
seem like it's a long death oh yeah they
just eat you they just hold you down
like a salmon and start chewing chunks
oh oh yeah they do yeah that cuz they're
omnivores omnivores of the worst thing
to get killed by you better off getting
killed by a predator because predators
generally just want to kill you and kill
you as quick as they can
but bears first of all there are no
predators other than other bears and
humans with rifles and if they're a
place where there's no humans with
rifles to the top of the food chain so
they just put a paw down on you so they
hold you in place and you start chewing
chunks of you just eating chunks of you
off the video the grizzly my special
midnight on Netflix you know my brother
called me up one time I I called him
after he had watched some video and it
was one of those Komodo dragons and it
somehow grabbed like a deer looking
thing whatever the [ __ ] is in its world
that's like that and it I'm sorry people
but it snapped its [ __ ] leg and he
said the thing was laying there and it
couldn't move and it would just started
eating the things guts and the deers
sound of I don't watch any of that I
don't want execution videos I don't want
that on my harddrive
mmm I'm gonna bomb tonight watching that
how do you find it that quick Jesus
Christ this guy's good he's got him
saved yeah there's a great one of a
komodo dragon eating a monkey and it's
got like look at it might be a baboon
it's a baboons are no joke I never knew
when they [ __ ] yawn you like oh [ __ ]
that's like a tiger monkey it's like a
dog monkey that's what it's like I got
to those Fang whoa crazy wolf monkey
yeah they kids somebody's got a new band
name that wolf monkey monkey that's a
good there's a great video of this
komodo dragon he's got this monkey's
feet and tail hanging out of his mouth
he's doing just slowly choking this
thing down eating this entire monkey
whole loot and the tail and a little
feet are pokin out as I talk see if you
can find that show the bill no I don't
want to I thought I see don't want to I
put it on that one so I don't I don't
want you can you do that while I talk
about my new special feeling up tiger
speaking of animals why'd you come up
with my paper tiger because I just think
we're in a hilarious time cuz you
already took strange time I have to stop
say like I like the amount of times I
had to stop saying it's a weird times
it's trance it's the name of Joe special
because it just is like what we're
focusing on like oh my god can you
[ __ ] believe this while this real
like half the [ __ ] that's going on if
it's true it's like you could make a
Will Smith or a Tom Cruise movie on
those end of the world movies where they
except you know it's not gonna have a
happy ending and it's just like it just
kind of strikes me I don't know and it
was also I just I wanted people to watch
it and have fun like I'm not trying to
[ __ ] hurt anybody it's not malicious
but I'm doing my job I'm talking about
what's in the news and I'm [ __ ]
around and it sparked that and then the
other part it's just me talking about my
flaws my temper and trying to work that
[ __ ] out that's all this [ __ ] thing
is and for some reason not just saying
stand up just a lot of [ __ ] that is not
as far as like if you had priorities you
know like if your house just burnt down
you're not being like god we have to get
a new toaster you know it's like now we
need shelter like that wisdom number one
thing but there's all this [ __ ] that's
like you know a line of importance like
line 42 is is getting gassed up to likes
number seven or number eight or
something like that and I already know
people are gonna be like you know
typical white male cuz you can't like
all of that [ __ ] you know there's just
something funny about how overtly I
don't know I guess reversed like it's
like you're doing the same [ __ ] thing
and you don't even realize you're doing
it as you're saying like a lot some
groups of people not all of them like
I've been joking how like a lot of
feminists are like
smart but it's not the ones that are on
TV it's like sports fans a lot of sports
fans are really smart but not the ones
that call in sports talk radio that's
perfect you know what I mean yes it's
like when we when we would do the Opie
and Anthony show okay like Howard Stern
like when he would do back in the day
when he would do live remotes I love
Howard Stern I love Opie and Anthony but
like if I was a fan of this show I don't
have time and I'm not going to some
[ __ ] mall in the middle of the day
blowing off work or whatever there
because I'm trying to get my own [ __ ] go
the people that show up you love them
because they're diehards but they're out
of their [ __ ] minds so it just has to
do with that I'm kind of it doesn't
necessarily have to do with me but it
does it's one of one of those things and
it's also another way of saying that I'm
full of [ __ ]
and you're a paper tiger yeah exactly
exactly so the Opie and Anthony days you
remember we used to have stadium seating
like small stadiums heating in the
studio and guys would come in us today
to let fans come in the studio yeah and
sit and watch the show
those are the good old days yeah iced it
every time I go to New York I add this
like it's like a void somebody said
perfectly like you know phantom limb you
know yeah that's what it feels like and
I get XM in New York and I'm gonna
doesn't exist that was the last show
that I used to get up early for only and
when they were together before Anthony
got kicked out and yeah then Opie and
Jimmy and Anthony were all together it
was amazing that was always like seeing
a band with all the original members on
the first [ __ ] couple of albums tour
before David Lee goes solo and then you
know well they were the first guys I
poured it over to XM to write mm-hmm
they were the first or I think they were
they before Howard or around the same
time but they were they would say I
think my name is they were on act that
was the one who was XM and then serious
before like Howard was on series they
were on XM and then they merged yeah but
they were the first show the first radio
show that let you just [ __ ] around like
Howard is amazing
right greatest
personality of all time by far but
Howard controlled the show he had you on
he had the board in front of him he
controlled the board he asked her
questions he had an agenda and you know
he was trying to make the show as
entertaining as possible and they got
ready yeah oh and then he just [ __ ]
come on in guys come on in Patrice come
on a bill Ari Shaffir have a seat and
everybody you'd be in the room breakage
your vase ten [ __ ] people in the room
Norton Norton would be doing [ __ ]
creepy characters I mean it was the it
was it was the birth Japanese Jimmy was
my favorite one that's like a deep cut
Jim Norton Jack talk Jimmy was one of my
favorite ones yeah it was so silly which
is my favorite thing ever highly
intelligent people being silly
yeah he's one of my favorite things ever
and I gem was the Patrice were sort of
the king of that oh yeah super super
super next-level smart and just silly
really silly I said when Howard went
from terrestrial radio to serious it was
like he died because I didn't have until
I got serious in my car so it's like my
favorite thing about my car because I
listen to them every [ __ ] morning if
I you know I gotta get them up and it's
like the old days like when I first came
to New York and I get to listen to it
David Berthe podcast whether they
realize it or not they were the birth of
podcasts because ona was like a podcast
like this podcast like we didn't even
talk about what we're gonna talk about
right not no [ __ ] discussion
whatsoever I mean obviously you and I
don't have to do that but we wouldn't
anyway we just come in here and shoot
the [ __ ] that's all they ever did come
on in shoot the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
going on
you know Anthony I'd have a gun on him
look deep cut Anthony character was the
guy with giantism did you ever hear him
do that guy no ah no I can't do it you
know the giantism and they get that
voice you know by the time I was a I
would not be tall I know he's going
they're dragging
and then like something like that would
happen and then it just felt like 2:00
in the afternoon somehow and you look at
your watch it was like [ __ ] 702 in
the morning do you remember when Anthony
did live from the compound he did a he
built a studio in his basement that's
when I was like Owen this is not gonna
last this guy's literally building it's
just like it's like we're in business
selling ice cream and I'm building my
own ice cream parlor at home no job I'm
in this business with you I knew like
like this I'm gonna fall apart you know
what's funny is what did that showing is
also what made it great yeah like you
know they used to play the ocean they
used to play this sorry about that they
used to play the the Clint Eastwood yeah
thing I always thought the theme to that
show should have been the wheels on the
bus go around and because it was just
like yeah and your thing was you were on
the bus but you were outside it you are
Hank it was you almost like I always
felt like when I went in there that
Raiders of the Lost Ark you know when
Harrison Ford's on the hood and you're
grabbing onto the foot of it and some
days you hung on and then other days
yeah except it didn't have the happy
ending didn't have the whip to hang on
to what you just [ __ ] do you know
were the day we were there and Pat from
Moonachie threw up in UK delphi's down
that was your idea yeah and then that
dude fan Nathanael came he was the one
that coined it the baby I got credit for
some reasons I think Dan's voice sounded
like me he came he came oh I've been
saying it's you know your idea was your
idea
you were like the only thing they could
top this for those who didn't see it
there's such a brilliant idea
it was the eggnog drinking contest and
you had to do a double shot like it was
bourbon but it was eggnog like every 30
seconds well Pat a returning champion
was Pat from Moonachie who had diabetes
and lost a toe to it already it was just
sitting there and then he continued to
drink it oh yeah to do the bit that you
came up with I think there has to be
like a you know when like a broadcaster
can get into the Sports Hall of Fame
just because you know you never play
the game but he like you know because of
what he added to it I always thought
that Pat Moonachie should have been like
they should have been like like like a
chick hearn Johnny most sort of award
that he [ __ ] can't with his his health
continued to drink I remember when
people posted that video everyone was
saying fake this isn't real that made me
enjoy it real is like no that was real I
was there those plastic bags all over
the ground
remember they they they put plastic
everywhere all over the ground because
they knew the people gonna throw up they
had the garbage can ready and then Pat
Duffy leans his head over the edge of
the garbage can and then pad from
Moonachie just here come you see him and
then it keeps coming it keeps coming
it's like way crazier it was a standby
you just yes [ __ ] came out and make
somebody kept shutting it off and every
time I mean it was like it is there I
can't watch this you know I still can't
tell the story if I tell it in detail I
start gagging I'll see fear factor
killed all that in me I never know I'll
tell the one that makes me gag I start
to gag is when there was the dude it was
tremendous do you I say I'll say it real
quick okay guys you're teared up haha
there was a dude who got knocked out so
then what he did was he started he puked
into a pitcher he puked into a pitcher
and then he was drinking his own puke
trying to make the other people puke so
then somebody dared this guy who had to
take a swig from it and he had like this
hipster Viking level beard I can't do it
this is like [ __ ] 10 years later he
took this Viking level swig he just so
he gave himself like kind of like a
facial with it and then he puked into
the picture I think and I remember it
was in his beard there's a point in that
podcast and in that puck and in that
show where I almost puke yeah doesn't
crazy thing about seeing everybody's my
people Bill's gonna go
Bilson I was like hanging on to the
[ __ ] table
yeah we didn't realize that the time
those are some of the greatest moments
of our life you know I got to figure
forgive yourself that because you were
in the moment oh yeah I was feeling like
melancholy when I was in Vegas you know
and I had you know I had this rout
sitting in my room smoking cigar with
Bobby Kelly Rick Thalia you know from
Boston scene right and we were sitting
then I was looking down at the strip
before they came over and I was thinking
about the first time I came out there
was right right before they imploded the
sands or the dunes or something they
were starting to implode those old ones
and just walking up and down the strip
in the real was the new hot one casino
and just all the great [ __ ] times
that I in crazy [ __ ] stories and all
that and then just walking around Vegas
being old now and seeing all these young
people like and you want to stop them
and just be like dude if you could this
any way to take this in do it because
you know at my age if I was to continue
doing that you're just a creep
I really respect younger people where
it's just like this is their time let
them have it that's their club yeah
don't be standing in there with your
white whiskers and [ __ ] listen trying to
listen to their DJ music just get the
[ __ ] let them enjoy their generations
drugs and let them have their [ __ ]
stories and just yeah yeah there's no
way you could impart that on anyone
though tell them to soak it up and enjoy
it I had moments or I remember thinking
when I was young like wow this is a wild
moment well I remember you that night
after the the baby bird we were at
Caroline's you are Caroline's and I went
down there and you had this debt that
[ __ ] grin in your face you like
really that's great radio I was just
like and I remember I told that I told
the whole [ __ ] story I came home me
it just started living with me and her
friend was there and I was telling the
story of what I saw that day and I was
laying on the ground crying laughing
telling and then this guy did this do
you
guy who was [ __ ] he would do his shot
and when anybody would puke he would
stand over in the corner and not face
them he was face in the corner so we
started calling him Blair which
everybody got this
so I'm crying laughing and then gagging
as I'm telling the story and then they
weren't laughing which made it even
funnier to me and then I just remember a
friend at one point just was like she
was like where do they find these people
and then that was that just sent me over
the top I was like I don't know just
crying laughing but god bless him yeah
where did they find these people well
that was a thing of like shock radio
shock radio gets such a derogatory it's
got such a derogatory connotation you
know shock jocks shock radio oh great
shock radio when you're a young guy and
you're a part of that and you're there
in the moment it's one of the greatest
moments of your life yeah it's so is
you're not shocked if there's thought
behind it shock is just like oh what
happened
[ __ ] those people that's just basic yeah
[ __ ] like I remember when I was
coming up you know and you would just
torn through the Boston scene and then
you you got on some show it wasn't it
wasn't news raid it was something else
hardball yeah and you were coming to the
Kowloon it's the first time I was gonna
see you do a set and all these guys and
always be so dirty so dirty blah blah
blah blah blah and I watched your set
and it's like this guy isn't dirty
there's like thought behind this like
anybody can do like a [ __ ] joke but
your joke was like you said you ever a
woman give you a [ __ ] it's like
brushing your teeth with your left hand
I'm like that's a [ __ ] killer joke it
just happens to be about a [ __ ] and
some people can't separate that yeah
well that was that bad that was back in
the day where there was still a bunch of
guys that were left over from the days
where Stephen Wright made it by being on
The Tonight Show and there was this
weird feeling to the air you know when
they talk about in stand when stand-up
stood out France Alamitos documentary
which is an amazing documentary yeah I
loved that but those guys before that
were just wild
they were just comics they were doing
blood they were getting in fights they
were chaotic and then Stephen Wright got
The Tonight Show and became a [ __ ]
superstar I mean a gigantic national
superstar and everybody else was like
hey what the [ __ ] what about me and I
came along after that and there was this
remnant of that there remember remember
Chris Zito yeah Chris Eidos giving me
advice when I was an open mic er
he was like you can't swear if you swear
you're never gonna get on TVs tell me
all this [ __ ] and it's like in his eyes
he was doing me a service right is that
was in his I'm a good place he came from
a good place in his eyes but I was like
[ __ ] he's gonna make me quit cuz like
this is what I want to do I'm like oh I
grew up watching Dice Clay and Sam
Kinison he goes well you're not Dice
Clay I'm like okay it's like well
neither were they till there but it was
bad advice from a guy who had made it
right he hadn't made it but he was at
least he was a professional and I was as
far from making it as humanly possible I
was an open mic ER I remember I went off
stage one night and he goes Joe [ __ ]
Rogan ladies and gentlemans Joe [ __ ]
Rogan didn't say [ __ ] enough like in his
eyes he was like look I'm just telling
you this because I care like you're
[ __ ] up your career alright so I had
it in my head I was like well I'm not
gonna do this then in my head I was like
I'm not I don't want to be that guy did
you ever notice I'm not that guy that
wasn't me I wanted I liked talking about
[ __ ] that made my friends laugh when we
were all sitting around drinking right
that's what was that's why I was in it I
was in it to talk about wild [ __ ] right
it didn't mean that you couldn't be
clever and talk about wild [ __ ] but I'd
never fit in anywhere in my life so the
idea of me fitting in like on television
that's almost like too weird from like
an offensive that there was like 9,000
stand-up shows on TV that you could get
on and you could become it wasn't just
the Tonight Show because The Tonight
Show which was the the biggest thing
yeah
but then there was the comedy on the
road it was evening at the improv comedy
half-hour come there was all of this
[ __ ] and so that's what they were
guiding towards and then I had the tail
end of that and then weird you started
90 92 92 so when I came it was a tail
end of the
at work clean and then it was you know
talk about your family so they can build
the show around you so you can do a
sitcom and I might be thinking like I
don't want to do a sitcom I can't say
that everybody had this idea in their
head that there was only one way to do
it the beautiful thing about all that
[ __ ] imploding is that there's none of
that now
now comedy is comedy and when you see
kids coming up now you know you go to
see the guys at the store that I like
doorman and open mic errs and I say guys
girls to alley makovski I take her on
the road me all the time and she's 23
you know she's just getting it together
now she's in that stage now she's like
five years in they just want to do
comedy man these kids just want to do
comedy well there's people now who cause
comedy is doing so well stand-up there's
people who like weren't comedians made
it as something else and now are
thinking about doing stand-up right yeah
you guys how lucky we are that we're
doing it now that's what I would think I
said it's it to my wife when I was in
Vegas is like you believe I get to do
this I love and I'm gonna hang and
[ __ ] as long as I'm doing it I still
love it I love it as much now as ever
maybe more now than ever I mean I don't
have to do it I do I do I would do five
six shows a [ __ ] week in town and I
love it no that's why you're great
because I always felt the guys that that
never stopped going to the club it's
that if look if you continue to tour and
you become like a draw you don't have to
go to the clubs in LA but you pay a
price you pay a price for that because
those kids coming up you're getting
something from them too much to say
watching you going oh wow you know
you're that guy that I saw and and you
know now I'm doing a show with you and
it's just like kid you're keeping me
young because like just being around
them you stay current yes
and it's white like why Damai rare
akil's just as hard in 2019 as he did in
2009 99 89 is because that [ __ ] guy
never stopped going to the gym yes and
stays in there so I get something out of
going to see I get you know something on
a watch and Dom out of watching you and
then
and some new kid coming up and just
being in all of that yeah
keeps you like current cuz if you don't
you start getting like a must
there's a like a [ __ ] you know that
old person died in smell stunting stop
laughing on your act yeah if you're only
doing it to your crowd to I think
there's a problem there to the one of
the beautiful things about the store is
there's fifteen guys on the show that
night they're there to see everybody
they they look at the lineup like oh
[ __ ] Bilborough [ __ ] Chris D'Elia Oh
Nikki Glaser's on they they see all
these great comics to me I do too
Christa Lee is like like from the get-go
like I could see like you know it remind
me like of a Boston guy where just like
it's like this guy's a legit headliner
just trying to kill just trying to kill
that's all he's do know and then his
concept of killing I thought was Boston
level oh yeah for sure well it's these
you know and particularly because he's
always at that right there that right
there is the last match no but that
right there is how I live my life
imagine that the hardest [ __ ] way to
do something why do you do that I do a
lot of things that way but not when it's
ineffective I mean that's one of the
reasons why I bowhunt well that's where
we're deep yeah see I like that like I I
feel if I was gonna go out and go kill
something cute and fuzzy if I [ __ ] had
a uh
you know total hypocrite cause I am a
mediator anyways if I used a bow and
arrow we would feel like an
accomplishment i watch Ted Nugent kill a
bear which I could never do you know
when there's all these [ __ ] places to
just get a chicken sandwich like do I
really need to make a [ __ ] you know a
bear double cheeseburger do you want to
try some bear sausage in the freezer
back there would you try it if I gave it
to you
no really no cuz I went to the zoo one
time and I saw this bear and it was
funny because it was sittin half in the
water and half out and had its arms
that's arms its front legs [ __ ] like
it look like it was sitting in a Jacuzzi
like a lounge and we pulled up on the
bus to look at it it was just the way it
looked I kind of locked I met eyes with
the thing and I knew always thinking put
like the video you know they're killing
the deer in the back
well it's eating it alive and the deer
screaming cuz you need to know what a
bear really is when you see bears in
real life you go oh that's what that
thing it's a [ __ ] killing bear would
just punch it in the head to stop
hearing to do this see that look at that
thing
no you're gonna buy the neck just no
it's taking chunks out of it bro
believes the reason why that thing's
screaming this is cuz it's biting its
back okay that's enough that's what
sounds like me trying to touch my toes
every morning you know it's hilarious
you know my daughter does one which she
likes to stretch with me she thinks it's
funny and she makes those noises cuz she
said she's supposed to
so she goes seek money she goes so cuz I
wanna stretch add that and then she goes
uh-oh
like I have like a foam roller and I'll
she'll come walk in a room and she'll
look at me she'll smile and just funny
she sits on it cuz she doesn't know how
to use it she sits down she just goes oh
my wife laughs at me that's he's
imitating how old you are
my kids are allowed to hit me as hard as
they can we teach them you know they've
taken martial arts classes but I teach
them and one of the things I do is I
have them lazy advice in that hair
because my I want my daughter to know
how to defend her jujitsu yeah I'll give
you I'll get you a good school near you
but I let my kids leg kick me full blast
just full blast I show them how to do it
where the shin slams I know I let him
[ __ ] slam into me well I've men do it
I mean I've been kicked by a lot you
know but there's an attrition to that no
your father's right you're 20 19 on the
inside he's got legs I let them I let
them slam their [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts man
but I'm letting them know like if
anybody ever [ __ ] you there's somebody
who [ __ ] you over some kid wants to get
into a fight
some girls picking on you slam one of
these [ __ ] right into her [ __ ]
thigh like it hurts me debate over yeah
teach them how to like defend themselves
it's it's also important that they
understand what it feels like to be in
conflict with someone like when I roll
them in martial arts classes when they
were young
like my one daughter was four there the
one was six when I first started doing
it and it's cool to watch them grapple
and do these things I'm like this is
what's good is like you know what it's
like to struggle with someone this is
not an alien thing for you to struggle
with a person when I watched my youngest
daughter grapple with this boy and
triple them and slam them onto the
ground and get on his knee and then the
instructors like good job
try again they're doing it again like
you know what it's like memory yeah well
otherwise it's a song for you yeah your
mind doesn't know what happens when
someone's trying to do something to you
whereas have you've done it it's not
alien I mean it's not like you should do
it you definitely shouldn't do it to
someone if they don't want to do it to
you but if someone's if someone senses
that you're scared of conflict it's one
of the surest signs you're gonna get
[ __ ] with and that was me a lot of no
I explained that to me a lot of my life
can end I've had both you know I went
from being a kid who was terrified of
conflict to being a martial arts
champion the reason why I became a
martial arts champion cuz I was being
picked on all the time right kids were
always [ __ ] with me I was like I don't
like this okay so I'm going to become
what I'm terrified of oh I should have
done that I was just like well school
ends at 3:00 realistically only do this
for another two hours and 45 minutes I
went the other way you said to teach you
they and they would have the two people
you know it would Eddie right way you
know Mikey bad way we should do that
do a little will make a kids book have
me let young me with a [ __ ] orange
afro there's only two hours and 45
minutes not knowing that knowing 245
minutes all the authority is gonna be
gone right opens everything now about
with mixed martial arts going mainstream
okay and there's no ref to get in there
at the video at all yes that's what is
scary and then everybody like like I
think with young kids it's like oh I
want to be the guy going oh you know
that that's who they want to be no one
wants to be the ref to jump in and say
stop they want to yell out worldstar
worldstar they want to do that and they
all want to have it
and then post it and get it to have some
hits like that's like you know I mean
I'm not [ __ ] on it because that's
what I would be doing if I was young I
got a video pulled off of Facebook and
Instagram and I got a community strike
Community Guidelines strike because it
was violence against minors but it was a
kid who was picking on another kid he
wouldn't stop [ __ ] with this kid and
then finally the kid just pushed him
away and then put up a stance like he's
ready to fight and the kid came out of
him he kicked him grabbed him slammed
him on the ground and got him in an
armbar and you know oh I saw that yeah
that was great it was a [ __ ] amazing
video and the kid didn't even get hurt
but it was a lesson I mean this is why
it's good to learn martial arts
yeah as this kid was a [ __ ] and he was
[ __ ] with this kid and the kid knew
how to fight right so I put it up there
like look this is this is the benefits
of learning a martial yeah and then
those people who who their hearts in the
right places don't post that because
that's gonna make kids fight other kids
no that's that's you're not going to
like through words and hashtags stop
having kids be kids be kids and it's
it's gonna happen and yeah yeah I mean
the idea that you're gonna protect kids
from reality by that it's just so it's
just so silly you're not you're not
gonna stop people from doing things to
people you gotta understand what is
happening when people do those things
and how you can learn how to fight so
you can mitigate most of it not and that
best part is other kids see you do that
and then you become the kid oh no [ __ ]
what that kids actually
yeah it'll dislocate your elbow yeah so
you want to be yeah I want to be the
nice kid who can fight so everybody
leaves you alone you know I went through
the entire eight that should be written
somewhere yeah be the nice kid that
knows how to fight there's a lot of
those kids now there's so many more it's
getting in a fight in school today with
someone you don't know it's a risky
proposition there's so many kids and no
jiu-jitsu so many kids that take more
time everything is on another level you
sure these [ __ ] kids coming up
playing drums oh yeah just the [ __ ] that
they can do is it's [ __ ] and bananas
really nobody could do this kids doing
[ __ ] that's beyond as far as
independence okay what they're doing is
beyond what I saw a lot of guys when I
would like when I first started buying
VHS tapes drum instructional videos now
they don't have this seasoned they don't
let necessarily have the feel and all of
that and know how to apply it
necessarily in a musical sense with the
because that just comes with experience
but what they have in their [ __ ]
Arsenal for chops is [ __ ] insane cuz
of YouTube you think yeah because you're
jamming with the world now right so it
becomes oh oh I'm gonna try that and I'm
gonna incorporate you know now the
people who do it the most basic level me
is I just see what somebody does and I
try to learn how to do it and I've only
now since doing comedy going like oh I'm
like a joke thief except I just took
that guy's groove that he just came up
with it's you're supposed to be inspired
by it to turn it into something else or
work on something else that you're doing
that's like another level that you know
eventually you get to I think as a
musician you do as far as me watching
them not as a musician but like just
seeing what these kids can physically
[ __ ] do it's in guitar plays the bass
players that I saw there's that one who
went viral there was that this little
girl from like Japan played good times
bad times like it was nothing and Robert
Plant is watching it like going this yet
and he's you something she's like she's
falling off a log which meant like it
was nothing
it was nothing to her I've been trying
to play those [ __ ] triplets my whole
life and I still don't have it down I'm
just like [ __ ] what is it about is it
just kids learn quicker because they
don't have as much [ __ ] in their head
well back in the day when you heard
something first of all you hit cassette
tapes there to keep [ __ ] rewinding it
and you're at the mercy of your own
bedroom like there's nobody in there
okay and now and then when you had the
record you could maybe slow it down okay
but even then you had you know you're
slowing it down there's still the
basement trying to get everything in it
it's hard to [ __ ] hear nowadays
somebody who's a [ __ ] expert or
whatever are so-called expert cuz you
know the guys who actually play goes you
know there's a lot of people teaching
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
like the Thermage
[ __ ] the show they'll break the whole
this thing
yeah this her yeah and her little cute
[ __ ] like she's adorable sock some of
those [ __ ] trip what she's doing it's
like it's nothing Fox look at her get
looted baguette later face oh my god
said door oh no she's she's killing it
that's the thing too is she actually
she's not just doing what John did she's
play she's playing it is she playing to
Led Zeppelin's oh he came yeah I was
that way okay can't play they're
actually smiling like we have a good
that's look I had a face when somebody
gave me an ice cream
how old one think she is 7/8 Wow look at
that she's a killer I think it's awesome
that you're into music it's another
thing like and I was thinking that too
when you were taking me up in the
helicopter ride like you do these other
things and you get really into them I'll
tell you what's crazy right now I'm
going for my instrument rating that's to
basically fly in like like if you come
into a city and like the whole city's
covered with clouds and you can't
[ __ ] see anything how to use your
instruments yeah this is this is what
separates the men from the boys right so
it's something that was really
intimidating so finally decided to do it
so the guy I'm taking the lessons from I
I don't know if I should say is that I
still want to blow up people's I never
know how much private they want to be so
I [ __ ] go in there because something
goes alright I know I know the guy I
know the guy I know the [ __ ] guy my
instructor goes I got the best [ __ ]
guy in LA so I go to his house cuz I'm
gonna fly on a simulator which is gonna
save me a ton of [ __ ] money initially
and then eventually so you know what the
[ __ ] you supposed to be doing when you
start spending a bunch of money what
does this emulator look look he's
simulus little computer screen he just
has like I got airplane yoke and a
throttle thing that's all it is but it's
getting you to look at like you have a
6-pack of gauges and then you have these
other two these these uh the OBS or
whatever it's a bunch of [ __ ] I don't
wanna [ __ ] try to explain here but
you're looking at that that becomes your
eyes that becomes looking out the window
is looking at your [ __ ] gauges and
it's unbelievably claustrophobic and
[ __ ] terrifying if if you got into
that type of weather and you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing that's how
you die okay now so anyways I go over
this guy's [ __ ] house he's hey how
you doing oh you know I'm so-and-so
what's going on I walk into his house
he's got a whole music studio and then
we're like a [ __ ] Grammy he has this
whole other [ __ ] life where he like
won a Grammy last year for writing a
song and some major [ __ ] superhero
movie and he's like a like a prodigy
piano player and then we go in the band
he knows and he's also he got into
flying and just took it to level that he
became an instructor and I just sit
across from the guy in awe go and all of
that is [ __ ] in that in that it's
[ __ ] unbelievable i --q outlining
like [ __ ] chapter four and the
[ __ ] thing but there's all like
gauges and [ __ ] and i'm little question
marks and stuff was like alright I'm
gonna figure out how to do this and it's
becoming less intimidating but I haven't
gone up yet but just as far as like
getting back to like these kids because
the fact that she's eight and can do
that is she hasn't got credit card debt
she's not in some [ __ ] relationship
date some loser kid who's playing videos
all day games all day and she has to
come up with her half the rent
and she has this whole [ __ ]
wonderment and [ __ ] is like the kids
like they're positive that stuff is
possible it's what do you wish you could
do that just have nothing but one thing
to concentrate on just completely free
of all the nonsense of life I'm not
wired that way it's weird my I think
that's why I like I'm not into speed
when driving I like to do it every once
in a while but like I like cruising
along because it relaxes me yeah it kind
of shuts down the [ __ ] thunder and
lightning of like let's do this let's do
this for ten minutes and I'll do this
for [ __ ] six minutes above oh and all
that [ __ ] so yeah I driving like the
right lane well you and I you and I are
very similar in that way that we have a
bunch of other [ __ ] that we do you get
into [ __ ] like heavily heavily
into something else yeah if I get into I
get into it does hurt me a little bit
because I'm starting to find like I
don't know what's going on in the world
which is scary as a comic so I got a dip
back in but it's healthier though well
but my wife but you also have to know
what's going on you kind of got to know
who's current and music yeah like I
learned that when I tried I needed a
reference for a pop star and I did it at
a college in like like four or five
years ago or whatever in the last time I
did a [ __ ] college gig and I used
Britney Spears as a reference and
they're all look like it just died and I
was like oh wait a minute she's like
mid-30s divorced mother of two but in my
world she was still 19 yeah we were
looking at Instagram numbers whose it
was the the the Selena Gomez or her and
Ariana Grande are up but I see on
renautas the rubber right but singers oh
yeah yeah like 190,000 million [ __ ]
Instagram I mean she's got 160 or some
30 and 150 or something [ __ ] insane
handling that in her twenties oh how do
you not be crazy and good luck when
you're older you know the Justin Bieber
had a post the other day on his
Instagram talking about all the drugs
that he did when he was younger and how
much it [ __ ] him up and now he's got a
relationship with the Lord and he's got
you know he's married and he's trying to
be a normal person yeah then he's
struggling with the fact that he was
insanely famous when he was a kid
yeah that's not that's not something I
would you know I like seeing people
become successful but that's not
something I would I would wish on
somebody no it's not the Domus wish like
he made it now yes but even then he's
still a kid he's like yes 24:25 better
now then making it at six you know when
you're a little kid and you become
famous like and you're the one calling
the shots you realize all these people
are you're responsible for their income
yeah mine's still developing and you
have everybody saying yes around you
yeah his brain is still developing now
is your frontal lobe isn't even fully
formed with your 25 he's I was gonna say
that but I didn't know that he's a baby
he's a [ __ ] young boy but he's you
know trying to figure it out you know
he's already I mean they were roasting
him on common sense
four years ago that's crazy and he
already had like 900 million dollars in
the bank
yeah it's that accomplished enough by
like 22 to get roasted yeah I mean most
people get roasted they're like [ __ ]
my age Alec Baldwin they don't they just
do yeah yeah yeah I love that guy big
fan his I don't know him do you know him
or you know I know I was on a flight one
time and he was sitting next to me
realize like I'm not gonna talk to him
we're not gonna bug him and then he just
leaned over with that matinee idol voice
he's like do you fly often and when I
found with him was if you just talked
about anything other than him you know
him being him he would totally talk but
the second I ever veered it towards what
he did he just didn't have any interest
in talk I was like I get it let's let's
so the time I did talk I just would talk
about you know anything but that well
have you ever sat next to someone I was
like hey how do you come up with your
material yeah it's [ __ ] bread I thank
you this is how I come up with it yeah
what was that one guy where you go and
bill was that one story Oh God oh that
guy that poor guy he was on something he
got all paranoid he had some sort of
military background he's gonna say yeah
all plain his how this idea that you
were a bad guy that was a hilarious
story though yeah he had the idea that I
was acting fidgety and nervous because
he was fijian nervous no I'm also a
[ __ ] lunatic I was probably [ __ ]
thinking of 50 things at the same time
as probably was acting that way but he
took it to the whole in love yeah he
stopped the plane Oh God we pulled over
cause if you don't [ __ ] you're new
today I'm gonna push that button I was
like [ __ ] push it oh that's right I
forgot that whole story he was a
military guy right
oh Jesus people that think they have
good instincts and their instincts suck
are the worst
like people think I've just got a good
we're reading people like actually you
don't
yeah well there's two ways to go into
something humbly and say I don't know
[ __ ] and as you learn [ __ ] and you think
oh and I'm starting oh my god there's
all this other stuff I don't know
yeah and then there's other people they
learn a little bit and then they're this
Authority Trump and then you get a
couple of drinks at them yeah excel you
know a plane has to pull over how did
they resolve that I don't remember I
don't really remember either was
something I'd dwelled on I just
remembered the stewardess coming over
talking to us like we were children like
are you two gonna be okay next to each
other and I'm just like I'm fine I don't
know what this guy's doing and he
continued to Yammer at me till he just
passed out and then I think when he when
we finally landed he was kind of sober
and I think he was starting to feel a
little stupid I think we've all been
there yeah we've all been there
yeah sure he's a nice guy maybe not
maybe not ending for the movie I don't
think that will test well with the baby
went walking through the woods one day
all right I'm gonna let you introduce
the next topic
maybe you got eaten by a bear that's a
way to go boy if you got to be eaten by
any animal what would it be no the
bigger the better sharp over quick uh no
not shark I don't like that because I
don't like my head being here in the
evils under here and it's gonna take a
bite out of me first to see if I'm
edible oh and you just sitting there you
know missing a chunkier leg going please
don't let me taste good please don't let
me taste good let him just [ __ ] leave
it's interesting sharks used to be if
you caught a shark people were happy you
got that [ __ ] thing out of the water
good like when fishermen would bring in
a shark people get excited yeah now
you're a monster
well there's there's this thing that I
follow about sharks on Instagram and
like it's [ __ ] this person found a
tiger shark the 18-footer or some [ __ ]
right and he she went down that she
somehow gain this thing's confident and
had like a fish some fishing line and
like took it out okay if this can't be
real and then somehow she ran into the
thing again in the ocean and she was
petting it like a [ __ ] lap dog trying
to suggest that this thing knew her knew
her and was happy and respect it mean
the way they cut it together and of
course the music always takes you
emotionally where they want you to go
but I was just watching that whole thing
going like it's good that you did that
but I don't think you're at the ican now
this tiger shark is talked to all the
other tiger shot not on out Bill's cool
do you remember Beastmaster remember
that TV show no there was a dude who's
like a jack dude and like big bracelets
on and he was mucking commune with the
animals and they would like land on his
shoulder and [ __ ] like Eagles would land
on his arm and all the animals would
listen to him really stupid show cuz
it's he there's no there's nothing
humble about that name piece masterpiece
master see they're allowing you to live
and your name yeah you gotta have been
Tarzan hare who was the guy in
Beastmaster who was it a TV show now it
was a show I think it was a TV show was
a TV show that guy like had this special
relationship with the [ __ ] with the
animals they all listened to him oh yeah
I didn't know he had a sword too so it
was a big dick to judge him by how long
that [ __ ] the man fought this huh
hang it down below his knees if you
don't have a big dick the line it's not
gonna listen to you look that Eagles
landed on his arm yeah he this was like
the Conan the Barbarian days like after
Conan the movie I was a giant hit there
was a lot of dudes with their shirts off
holding swords holding swords there was
a thing
tell him lions way to go yeah it was
I'll tell you one thing that I would
never do in acting is I will never ever
III catch I probably shouldn't say this
but like working with monkeys aside from
you know it's going to be a bad movie no
[ __ ]
way I worked with the writer who got
attacked by a monkey when he was a kid
and it was just one of those
organ-grinder ones they [ __ ] him up
those [ __ ] show business man it's
gotta thanks for the organ grinder music
and their fat monk and he was talking
about like his clarity and understanding
of monkeys just by getting attacked by
one he goes nah he goes I won't do it he
go she do like you're good for about 18
20 minutes and then the monkey just
starts [ __ ] acting crazy and then
eventually it just gets like you know
I've always said that you go to a circle
like a circus like a bear doesn't want
to ride a bicycle
so what did they do to that [ __ ]
thing to make it give in
yeah and it's a bear so eventually it's
gonna become a bear again you know and
it something's got like all like those
circus all that [ __ ] it's just that it's
inevitable like what you're doing yeah
circus is a dark is that what they do to
elephants and monkeys and bears there's
a great video it's not a good well it's
horrible do you have any happy videos of
animals just existing I don't save those
I know you're done just I'm chilling out
there's a video of a chimp ride the bike
and a girl in a bear riding a bike and
the chimp tripped up the bear somehow
and they crashed and the bear grabs a
whole that chimp just rips it apart from
everybody
what's that [ __ ] yeah here it is so
the Bears riding and the chimps riding
and they collide and when they collide
the bear is [ __ ] furious at the chimp
and just starts [ __ ] ragheads like
road rage right boom goes down and he
tries to help him back get back on the
bike is this it is this the one oh he's
got the chimp right there
oh yeah it's too late I thought they'd
have a muzzle on the [ __ ] thing well
not this time they trusted him so he
just [ __ ] up that chimp and they can't
get it away from him
that's not even a big bear it's a small
bear no dude that's [ __ ] huge
would you want to fight that guy in a
bar no guy that stocky red hairy coming
at you that's Georgie animal steel it's
just such a stupid [ __ ] form of
entertainment you know let's get animals
to do [ __ ] that they don't normally do
people are freaking out ah I like it
took them that long to stand up to
realize that's not part of the show
something about music you can just take
you emotionally where you want them to
go ripping them apart like you imagine
that that used to be show business you
used to be like you know covered wagon
you'd pull into town ladies and
gentlemen gather around and there was a
show and then you know you have a
minstrel show and people would sing and
do puppets and there'd be a play and
you'd yeah that's when when do you think
the first guy got up and told jokes and
made people laugh like when was our
first Oh who's that guy he wrote that he
wrote that great book on the history of
stand-up and it was a guy like Frank Fay
or something like that
uh-huh was the first guy that went out
there like I don't need to have like a
[ __ ] hula hoop and spinning plates
and he just went out and was like I'm
just gonna tell stories and make him
like he kind of did a monologue type of
thing but uh he was the first guy if I
haven't Rises that I think was the 20s
and then in the 40s he was actually on
the side of the fascists he was a
fascist yeah there was really yeah there
was people in this country that you know
didn't think what those guys were doing
was necessarily wrong which really if
you look at the history forget about
this country a humanity like there's
always been that so what [ __ ] his
career if I'm remembering this correctly
this could be like [ __ ] hope I'm
saying the right guy he so he ended up
doing this
yes Frank faced and he did this show all
right I guess that's earlier when he's
doing the props he's come out dressed
like he's in the Foreign Legion but he
did a show right after World War two
right after he won and it was a pro
fashion
rally in New York City and he was the
big name he signed on to do it and the
night was called the Friends of Frank
fain the first stand-up comic was a
fascist house I know I can't say I don't
I don't know that but then there's other
people that I got a body mind that will
argue that that Mark Twain was Samuel
Clemens
yeah well argue will argue that he was
the first stand-up so I don't know
really nice I think it just sort of they
would sort of poked its head up and then
ducked back down like somebody improv
the line like hey I did that without my
hula hoop
you know they got sick a lug and [ __ ]
around or something I don't know what it
was but uh did you ever see Lenny with
Dustin Hoffman yeah it's [ __ ] great
in that I mean he really came off like a
comic you know he seemed like he was
Lenny Bruce now he's an incredible
incredible acting I actually went down a
rabbit hole looking up a bunch of [ __ ]
about him and oh no it wasn't that I
don't even hind went down this rabbit
hole the things he's [ __ ] talk about
like before 9/11 like what you could do
and then still walk around a free man
like 18 months later it was crazy like
these people on the Upper East Side I
don't know what the [ __ ] they were doing
this really radicalized time like the
60s early 70s um where around that time
these people were making a bomb right
yeah and like these rich kids are some
[ __ ] because it was like a 2 in a
townhouse on the Upper East Side and
Dustin Hoffman had one on that block
close enough to it and you know these
[ __ ] idiots blew themselves up blew
the [ __ ] building up and [ __ ] with
his townhouse and there's a picture of
him if you can find it is he grabbed
some piece of expensive art that he had
bought got it out of his house and it's
a picture a young Dustin Hoffman walking
up the street yeah
this poor guy like had the balls to go
after a dream you know you think it's
hard making as a comic I don't even know
how the [ __ ] he made it as an actor now
forget about then yeah look at it blew
up their whole [ __ ] thing and he's
like I made it I'm on the Upper East
Side
everything's great and then these
[ __ ] the building's missing yes so he
owns something close enough to that yeah
Jesus Christ it's crazy it's like all
the building to the building to the left
fine building to the rise fine and that
buildings obliterated yeah I'm sure that
there was some damage there's other ones
so but it's crazy how the one in the
middle just missing no but if you look
it up like that the the jail time that
they got the wall I mean you know
obviously the person who was down there
the people down there died I think but
then there was they figured out who was
in cahoots with them but also their
parents owned a townhouse on the Upper
East Side
oh so they place and Jimmy spent a
little you know distant your honor you
know you know they go to the same
[ __ ] party yeah you get away with
[ __ ] before the Internet they passed
around some cash do you ever see a
doctor check who shot [ __ ] Andy Warhol
barely did any [ __ ] time and then
years later how he died I always thought
he died on a deep drugged himself first
though just doing drugs a party but I
think it was complications from the
bullet wound yeah when you when you get
like shot like I also think oh yeah
Morgan damage well when you get shot in
the gut - that's like [ __ ] worse
because all that [ __ ] that breaks down
your food seeps in like the infections
and the dish oh yeah it's horrific would
not show him for I don't know I don't
know I'm not saying he I'm not saying
anybody was a great [ __ ] person here
but that's never a solution but the jail
time that that person got was
ridiculously short and then he's got to
live the rest of his life dealing with
the fallout of what that person did to
him and then also knowing that that
crazy chick is out there
well isn't a guy who shot Reagan out now
no I think they were gonna let him out
and he was like no guys no you don't
wanna do I think he said that I thought
they let him out
my memory isn't the greatest I'm
probably combining all three of these
stories and it's actually about he's out
quick-quick he says he's released so
what's his name again John Hinckley
Hinckley yeah you should look up
everything I say actually bill it's
completely the other direction do you
ever watch a documentary on the
Weathermen do you remember the
weatherman no with the weatherman we're
a radical terrorist group from the 60s
like some Ron Burgundy [ __ ] okay 6007
that's what that Greenwich bombing has
something to do with that there's like a
group called like the SDS the students
of Democratic Society which was an
offshoot of the whether meant I'm gonna
just look into their Wikipedia this
where they radicalize rich white kids
maybe well one of them one of the guys
who was one of the Weathermen went on to
become a professor at a university in
Chicago and that was one of the things
that they were talking about when Obama
was running for president he's friends
with a terrorist because he knew this
guy from his from his university days
alright because wasn't that like the
idea and Fight Club that the Project
Mayhem something like that you want to
talk about that's the same sort of idea
or they just wanted to [ __ ] up all sorts
of different things in society and not
troll people by bomb [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about yes we should ask Chuck
when he was in here
mmm-hmm but the weatherman anyway the
documentary is crazy they were they
wanted to take down society and they
wanted to take down the government so
they were doing acid and having orgies
and places and blowing things up and
there was no like so then we can rebuild
it it was just like [ __ ] it up I mean I
think there's a lot of anarchists a lot
of people in the their youth where they
want to just tear the whole [ __ ]
thing down you know I was having a
conversation with my wife about this
really interesting just the other day
we're out at dinner and she was like
when she was young she had a rough
childhood and she was hoping that
society would fall apart cuz her life
was a mess and other people's lives were
great and she had this thing in her head
like she hopes society crumbled because
then everything would be [ __ ] all over
the world no one would be okay because
her life wasn't okay I'm like that's
really interesting yeah really
interesting cuz her insight the way she
was talking about it was like because
she was remembering that very
specifically when she was young you know
chaotic that's why that Tarantino movie
so so like funny to me I loved it I
don't think they ever say hippie without
saying [ __ ] [ __ ] hippies well
there's always been ample like that
right there's always been people who
want to take that whole [ __ ] thing
down you know I want to know when you
can buy that movie and own it like what
out cuz back in the day just buy like
the DVD cuz that is like like you're
going on tour that's like that's going
be a Goodfellas movie for me where I'm
gonna watch that thing 5,000 times in my
life and always see something new in it
and then it becomes like like the second
time I saw it I realized how great the
actor playing I'm trying to talk all
this surface yeah don't give any spoiler
alerts well this this guy he plays a
director that's gonna direct leonardo
dicaprio and like what that guy does
with that role and how many inside jokes
you don't have to be in show business
how [ __ ] funny that guy is it's like
well you know the 90th time I watch
Goodfellas I realized how funny that guy
was the guy who had the wigs like yeah
how [ __ ] hilarious and how great that
guy played that degenerate gambler
because it the first time you watch it
it's like Joe Pesci and De Niro you've
seen all of those guys and then you
start to like Frankie Carbone and you
know the roast beef guy and all of that
[ __ ] but then you've just watched and
what just looks like everybody is great
in this yeah everybody took like ears
one or two lines and everybody just like
hit a homerun
you know what freaked me out in that
movie that I couldn't believe the
violence against women like the scenes
the fight scenes I'd only give anything
away but there was some what you like
whoa you could still do this in a movie
like holy [ __ ] that's my favorite quote
from Tarantino what I saw an interview
one time and they were saying yeah we
know it's trying to write movies and
stuff you know and they were going like
you can't do this you can't do that he's
like why maybe because I do another [ __ ]
I want it's like that well that's why
you movies are great yeah what are you
like you just like that's that's the
comic I want to watch I can say whatever
the [ __ ] I want yeah good I want to see
you totally unfiltered yeah that's good
I mean there's a time in a place I think
you know you know to to be filtered sure
you know what I mean there's no sense
just going in and showing your ass and
being it you know right if somebody
hires you for a private gig and they go
okay perform between these two lines
you're not Lenny Bruce if you go in then
you go outside and you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right because you agreed to do
that right you do a corporate gig for a
Christian Church right but if you're at
like a
it's like no you you're a guest yeah you
came into a nightclub so right this
isn't you know if you don't like it you
leave but I came to see you specifically
and all the other people did too and the
one or two people that'll get upset well
you're the problem the other people are
there to see this kind of [ __ ] it seemed
so selfish it'd be like if I went to a
restaurant and I didn't like the meal
and then the chef owed me an apology and
had to change his menu and you didn't
want anybody else to eat stop yeah I
hate this food and if you go in there
and eat off of that menu then you're
part of the [ __ ] problem and I'm
gonna try to take you down - yeah cuz
you didn't have a problem with this
[ __ ] chicken and dumplings whatever
the [ __ ] making strange time strange
best name special I feel yeah well I
didn't know what else to call it just
that's all I could think of yeah I like
it because it's not it's not you're not
punching them in the nuts you just said
strange it's a weird time yeah
paper tiger yep how long do you think
you're gonna wait to do another one do
you have an idea in your head you gonna
try to do two years we try to do a set
schedule never think that no because
that takes the enjoyment out of it it's
like more like I had a bit that I was
doing the first time I told the story in
my new hour two women like yelled out
simultaneously and they yelled the same
thing which means they whispered to each
other let's yell this in three two one
and I got out go [ __ ] yourself I got
into that with them and then they went
upstairs and I'm like it's a comedy club
I know they're still there because
comedy club security is the worst it's
the worst they just they just they they
don't know how to kick people out so I
went upstairs I had to put the hoodie up
and all of that [ __ ] they said they were
at the bar I walked by and then I go
outside the club took the hoodie up and
then they were there and then we got
into it again and I was just like you
don't even know me go [ __ ] yourselves
you know what the [ __ ] I'm saying [ __ ]
you [ __ ] with him Anna just my
perception on something I was telling a
[ __ ] story right so
and it had to do with a lesbian so that
and then it was the wrong show to do it
on cuz I think it was kind of a gay show
I mean I went up there they had paper
cutouts of dicks all over the place so
I'm like i but it's a comedy club so I'm
tell I'm telling the story I want to
tell so I told the story and you know so
it took me a little while you know to
kind of imagine I pretty much of me it
was like you know I don't want to have
that kind of interaction with people so
I've just been you know working the bit
out working a bit out and then like you
know I did the joke the other night at
the Laugh Factory and the exact person
from that group came up to me told me
she loved the joke and she was just like
I feel like you would describe in my
life and I'm like that's why that's the
fun of this [ __ ] and you know as people
say like oh you're working on a joke I
can't do it at home yeah I have to go
out there and just start throwing [ __ ]
against the wall and see how to piece
this stuff together so to go back to
like when are you gonna do a special
again like I enjoy this part too much to
rush it we had to be thinking about like
you know then you're like okay I'm doing
is special I'm taping it here and then
I'm in the bubble and then every night I
go onstage and it's just like okay and
then I gotta do this and maybe what if I
open with this and what if I put in and
just it just becomes you know this is
added weight to it mmm that makes it
like you know the opposite reason the
entire reason why I got into this
business was not that [ __ ] real job I
wanted to have fun
so this which just goes back to what I
was talking about you when I was
watching us a flock Joe's on the other
side he shot his special and now he's
going down and as much as it can be
frustrating putting it together he's
having fun every night seeing alright
where's this idea gonna go yes it's
gonna leak cuz this sitting like when
I'm putting together a new hour like I
have some of the hacky as [ __ ] ever and
I take all of those rules and throw them
out the window I don't give a [ __ ] if
you see me doing these jokes and most of
them don't live but some of them grow
into something better yeah and then it's
not hacky and now it's this this thing
that then shoots off into this
then you just start spinning off over
here yeah yeah and then all the say I
got like I got like eight minutes I got
12 minutes they're seeds right yeah it's
starting to come together so when people
go down there and it's literally like
it's not even done you're just starting
to draw and they're reacting to it
saying it sucks and it's like it's it's
not done I'm just yeah I agree with you
it sucks yeah yeah yeah I'm with you
yeah this is our workout but some people
know that some people understand that
some people think they're come to see if
most product most people now today in
2019 yeah crowds are great yes it's just
one person in 50 shows complains and
it's you know because there's so much
[ __ ] to look at like controversy gets
people to stop at your website and then
you get credit from the advertisers in
the side and then they they gas up [ __ ]
and they donate they you know I saw a
guy recently talking because you know
suede everyone in the internet hates me
but I walk down the street and everybody
loves me so it's just like so what is
what's really going on there's what's
going on is is the small that percentage
that don't like you is being shown to be
the majority you know well it's a very
vocal minority who get upset about
things and they're very they're adamant
about it and they're very active that's
what it is the people that are upset
about certain things people that are and
they're really respond specifically it's
long if you know because then you can do
exactly nine times out of ten exactly
what they're complaining is being done
to them they turn around and then do
trying to find their justice and they
just I don't know the irony seems to be
lost on these people but like I don't
talk about I try not to talk about that
[ __ ] a lot because I don't want to give
it any more added weight than it
deserves and it's just like bullies if
people bring it up I just say you know
not everybody's gonna like me yeah I
don't know what to tell you I don't need
everybody like I just need enough people
to fill up enough of wherever I'm
playing so I can continue doing this
that well it's only that like as a
comedy fan like what you're doing right
now like that what you're doing under
special the stuff that I saw
working out before the special is what I
always wanted to see as a comedy fan
that's what I like I like I like people
who take risks who say crazy [ __ ] that
you know you know is you're walking out
on a line you know you're on a wire you
know I want to see you what like the
dead troops bit you're walking a [ __ ]
wire and you could feel it you can feel
buttholes clenching up wow you start the
bit I love it that kind of comedy to me
is the most fun especially now at this
day and age with all my years in comedy
if something still makes me go oh [ __ ]
where's he going yeah the thing is if
you're gonna keep being a comedian then
you know how to do it yeah so then
you're just gonna be bored if you just
wrote [ __ ] that you knew the crowd was
gonna like about la but to then
challenge yourself to kind of a can i
yeah can I say what I think about this
in a funny way that doesn't put people
because I don't I am NOT that guy I
don't want to walk the crowd I don't
want to have people waiting to yell at
me right there's certain people that
liked it and kind of want to be that
person that's not what I'm trying to do
I just want to make you laugh and I
definitely you know will steer into err
okay I have a lot of silly [ __ ] through
but I'll steer into some areas or
whatever
but it's all like just done and fun it's
just done in fun it's just so you just
listen some idiot in a bar that's all
you do exactly and if you're not there
to see that well then you picked the
wrong play it's not legislation now you
know go home yeah I just saw a great
quote Joan Rivers said that when she
separates of all time what'd she say
sanika media should never apologize for
a joke
it just means you didn't get the joke
and that [ __ ] was ruthless
oh she was ruthless till the day she
died she was ruthless no I saw her I saw
her towards the end of a life and I was
just going like I couldn't pull that off
I couldn't pull that off but like she
was also somebody that like was like
Carlin where it was they didn't just go
Kay I got here and we're satisfied they
just kept mmm going to higher and higher
levels and
that I'm telling you if you watch her on
The Ed Sullivan Show okay in the 60s
when her act was at versus the 70s and
then the 80s than the 90s this very few
artists that you watch that their
trajectory is this continuing climb Jack
Lemmon one of my favorite actress of all
time you watch him in the apartment his
great is he is in that Jack Lemmon and
Glengarry Glen Ross blows away Jack
Lemmon in 1960-61 because you know not
like I know the guy but like if you
don't take the ride is what I call it
you know when people say yeah yeah you
says yeah I'm [ __ ] yeah that that's
when you just level off and you start to
go back down if you keep going like I
can learn from younger people you know
from older people peers you'll continue
if you but but it's it's constant like
work yes if you put the work in like I'm
hoping because both of them fascinate me
equally Carlin and Joan Rivers how they
they went they went like this you know
and and I'm Carlin was so [ __ ] out
there I thought there was comedians that
didn't get what he was doing towards the
end and now you go back and watch what
the [ __ ] he was saying in the 2000s and
all of that [ __ ] is happening and it was
just he was ahead of the curve if people
thought he was overreacting or now he's
just this angry old man it's like he saw
where yeah don't you need to go back and
listen he's trying to warn you about
some [ __ ] and he was just a hundred
percent I mean just [ __ ] up on the
money like I can watch [ __ ] that he said
in 1990 and be like yeah like that that
actually I know what that is right now
like that's it's it that's not like you
that's almost like 30 years ago and you
don't watch it like he's up there like
hey take my wife please it's not like
this it's like a timeless thing well
some people I think the struggle of
doing the work of showing up the clubs
of grinding that feeling of you know go
on stage with the seeds of new material
and eating [ __ ] not knowing where
they're going to Taking Chances going on
a limb and failing and then succeed
and then finding punchlines and new new
ways to take the bit and then all you
one night you ad-lib something and holy
[ __ ] that's it this is the whole thing a
little piece at all that yeah you find a
wormhole into another dimension and you
you piece it all together people get
weary they get tired of doing that I
think it's a retirement but I also think
I think it's a the fear of those stories
we were talking about earlier is like
the humiliation of trying to learn how
to actually be a comedian yes or being
in a band anything that involves getting
up on a stage you don't want to go you
don't want to feel that again right so I
think people will like okay I'm doing
this and this works and then then says
fear well I'm finally drawing tickets
because everybody I'm give a [ __ ] who
made it like most of us had that feeling
in a comedy condo of like am I the guy
who's not gonna [ __ ] make it what am i
don't and that [ __ ] cold sweat
failing I I think people who stopped
growing it I think part of it is that
you don't want to go back to what the
[ __ ] did I said something the other
night on stage and it bombed so [ __ ]
bad it was like a vacuum I can't go back
I didn't get sucked into my own bike it
was a chest it was a lot an old joke to
get it so I could get a drink of water
like foo not tighten up the midsection I
was just sitting there like right in the
liver liver shot it wasn't a liver shot
because I would have gone down and we'll
plexus it was yeah it was definitely I
had to regroup and get back on the yeah
I'd stepped into like a sinkhole that
one that that could still happen though
I like that that can still happen I like
things that scare the [ __ ] out of me I
always have I'm into them I'm not into
safe things I like it when it goes off
the road and into the trees I in certain
parts in comedy I do I don't like that
in life ya know personal relationships
oh no not gonna get scared I don't like
that either yeah that's that could be a
problem yeah I think that we all can
learn like if we keep doing it I think
one of the dummer era told me this too
he goes Joe one of the things I really
love
how many he was I think I'm better than
I've ever been he does I've been doing
this comedy for [ __ ] 40 years I agree
I agree with it as well but it's because
his love of it you know Dom loves it
like he'll go on stage in the or and
they're bringing him up you know ladies
and gentlemen you see this kind HBO and
this and that and then there's all those
[ __ ] credits and he walked onto that
stage with a big smile on his face is
the best part of his day yeah he's gonna
go up there and [ __ ] murder anybody
give a better [ __ ] on you in a intro
than him one of my favorite things that
the store is like Dom's bring you up I
can't wait to hear what he says about me
yeah and it's always like this he does
his complimentary while he's taking your
photos he's a fantastic on kill Tony
he's one of the best guests ever on kill
Tony because you know okay yeah because
those comics go up and they do one
minute and so many of them are brand new
they might have done stand-up once or
never before and surfer can't believe
those kids had the balls to do that so
as I would took great show it's a great
show because of that and Tony's such a
great host and him and red band [ __ ]
with the people but my favorite by far
side guest is when DOM is a guest check
that because he's so [ __ ] good at it
he's so good at [ __ ] on bad comedy
they have complements you and half
[ __ ] at you at the same time I used
to love a show that he used to do at the
Laugh Factory busting balls with dimer
era yeah he would do I did that yeah
they would sit on Jamie Masada say that
you did say that you did ban me from the
club listen to all this [ __ ] I don't
know who put your stuff on YouTube was
not me buddy he's not me but then ya die
never owns up to the fact he banned me
from the club one time that never
happened what a man you he was doing
this thing where he wanted people to
work clean or something and I went up
there and admittedly I you know just
some nights you get on stage you start
saying [ __ ] and you can't stop it was
one of those sets
and he goes buddy what happened man you
know you go up on stage you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] all over the place man and I just
laughed I thought he was [ __ ] around
and then I all of a sudden I wasn't
getting spots and somebody gave me
advice call him up and apologize uh and
then he knew he had me I apologize and
then he just [ __ ] with me how long ago
was this late 90s fun times fun time
they were not fun times in the store was
not fun but he would go down the store
there was like nobody there and it was
just these [ __ ] famous comics which
is drop-in and they would do like hours
oh yeah anyway and they didn't do the
work they hadn't written anything and
they're just standing in the mics in
yeah so what else is going on and they
were teaching all these young comics
they're like someday when I get on a
show I'm gonna [ __ ] do that I'm gonna
come in their house and I remember being
like this is what it is what the [ __ ] is
this and then this all late 90s then I
went down to the improv in Seinfeld just
write his Seinfeld had wrapped up it was
the first time I was seeing him live and
it was like Jerry's popping and oh okay
I want to see Jerry and he had a 20
minute spot and he did 20 minutes
it came up he opened with something that
worked he closed with something that
worked and he worked on his new [ __ ] in
the middle
twenty minutes got the light wrapped up
thank you good night I remember thinking
like that guy's a [ __ ] pro a pro yeah
there was a time where that was a thing
to do were guys but you know and I think
Chris Rock would do it work that's how
he would come up with material and he
would party would say to the audience
don't get too excited the shankha that
funny right he would say that like he
would go on after somebody that killed
like someone to do like 15 minutes right
of all their best [ __ ] and then Chris
would pop in so Chris would go up
afterward and he go what else what else
and he would like I think it was a
strategy to put himself in these bad
positions hoping he would find a way out
of it and then he would take those
little chunks that he would find when he
would find a way out of it and then
build those into bits but he knew he
wasn't one of those guys that went up
and just did two hours not two hours
because he was Chris Rock you do like 20
minutes yeah
was always like whenever I saw him pop
in I would always watch because he was
worried he had written stuff yeah and he
was working on it and it was I know who
you're talking about yeah yeah I know
who talking about exactly yeah that
would do there's a couple guys that
would do that yeah oh it was the worst
it was bad because they weren't even
trying to be they weren't trying to
entertain the crowd and they talked
about them being famous yes and by the
time they were done the [ __ ] show was
done people just get up and droves cuz
it wasn't entertaining yeah yeah yeah
well those days are done you know that's
the beautiful thing there's no more of
that a couple people who tried do that
you know a couple people have come in
like fairly recently that are famous and
run the light and then done 45 minutes
to try to do that and they can't come
back they've had a few of those people
try to stop in I never I never thought
that that would I always thought that
Fame would win that one that's that's
that's good to hear that the guy and
they're actually doing the person a
favor well you know why they can't do
that anymore
that's the shows are sold out every
[ __ ] night at the store and it's
packed with killer comedians you can't
do that anymore you can't go on in
between you and D'Elia and Joey Diaz and
just what else what else you can't do
that anymore those days are done yeah
you got to bring it after Joey those
days are done yeah
Jesus Christ Joey Diaz we leave a
[ __ ] hole in that room he leaves a
hole and you got to fill that [ __ ]
hole in before he can even start to tell
jokes yeah I love Joey he's a monster
I've never seen anybody kill harder in
my life I've been doing comedy 31 years
I've never seen anybody kill her Joey he
has a command he's a monster you know
and he goes out there it's like alright
the captain's here yeah he's a monster
he hit some hind and also by the way
he's doing comedy from 1990 he's doing
comedy like me - never happened the
internet never happened there's no
[ __ ] rules yeah it does not give a
[ __ ] and just really doesn't kills
because murder people yeah don't give a
[ __ ] what if I had an ax toxic right
[ __ ] wait they say it's just like
they know they're seeing jokes they know
that he's [ __ ] around right he's
funny
yeah and it's good that's the other
thing too it's ridiculous outrageous but
it's also really well word well worded
well
[ __ ] right yeah this is how much good
come somebody was telling me there's a
thing out there now that if somebody
shows up who's hard of hearing you're
supposed to have a device for that to
help them out and if they don't they can
sue you so there's a there's some
[ __ ] ambulance chaser hard-of-hearing
guy going around so when well I've done
shows where they had a sign language
horse and you've done that right well
they have to do with certain theaters
like but my thing is it why is it on the
club it's like you know your hearty
hearing yeah how the [ __ ] I gotta hire
somebody yeah if you have a limp do I
have to make sure there's a cane there I
did cobs once and there was a guy in the
audience that was deaf and he actually
hired someone to do sign language so
someone was sitting facing him while I
was like he was facing me and someone
was sitting like say if if Jamie is the
audience member and you're you're you
know like this TV's worst an abyss this
lady was doing this and then doing this
to him doing this and doing this to him
and the guy was like like kidding wha
and so I was going what's going on here
and then I had to sort it out right all
you hired her to do he goes yeah I bring
her to Lena we explain I bring her to to
comedy clubs how could you bring her
movies like he's like it's like this guy
had this lady that he would hire and she
would do sign language for him look good
for him though you didn't make a big
deal out of it he just he hired somebody
that's actually great so you can go to
movies and nobody talking bugs him
people eating their popcorn too loud he
doesn't he only needs to see a movie
once he gets all the [ __ ] dialogue he
doesn't get the music the manipulation
the music gives you that [ __ ] doesn't
work on him oh that's interesting
yeah this music drives me nuts in movies
I mean I like it it adds to movies but
there's sometimes when I'm aware of it
that's when it bothers me when I'm aware
when there's like piano playing and the
guy and the girl holding hands when I
come on right you didn't need to do this
to me or if they pick a hacky song oh
that you've seen in like 40 different
movies it's like alright yeah yeah that
was cool when Scorsese used it in 1980
but so it's an interesting thing because
it came from the time where there was no
sound in movies so they would add a
musical soundtrack
because movies were silent and you would
see the screen with the words would come
out so we from then associated movies
with music it's a weird thing like these
people are talking there's a shootout
there's a [ __ ] fight and I'm in a
scene in a movie in a comedy club or
whatever in the movie and then this
music plan and all this stuff's going on
like why is there music playing why you
manipulate because they've always had
music in movies so from the time they
had movies were there were silent there
was music playing in the background they
just kept it in there like it doesn't
make sense that music is in movies
you're showing me scenes of things that
are supposedly really happening and I'm
supposed to be locked in like the really
happening but there's this unexplained
[ __ ] music the corresponding action
on this there's an art to everything for
sure if use properly yes sure there's
art but it's amazing that we
automatically associate those two things
together right because music is a
totally different thing than a movie but
yet they're inexorable to us we I
wouldn't want to watch jaws without that
[ __ ] thing boom yeah of course yeah
[ __ ] have one that's all I would think
when I'd hear that no it's back I wonder
if when they first invented movies if
they already had invented audio
recording because it's kind of crazy
they invented video recording before
audio you would think that it'd be no
there used to be a tendon if some person
would be playing the piano sure sure
sure sure they did that too yeah that's
what I thought on I think I think they
did that too but they definitely if you
watch an old silent movie there's music
playing you know I watch the thing on I
like those Turner Classic Movies and I
was watching this thing they did a whole
thing on Buster Keaton was [ __ ]
unbelievable it was I was I recorded
I've watched it like three times
do you like I broke his neck doing a
[ __ ] stunt it wasn't even aware that
he did it he was definitely in pain he
was doing some gig that some bit there
was like a train coming down you know
the water spout thing that you pulled
down yeah the joke was that it came down
on him but they didn't understand they
didn't you know the physics of it how
hard that water was coming out and
slammed him down onto the train tracks
you don't there's so much water you
don't see how he hits but he broke his
[ __ ] neck and didn't realize and then
years later he went to the doctor with
some headaches or something like I don't
know what the hell it was but the guy
was going on he's just looking at the
x-rays like so don't you break your neck
because I never broke my neck he goes
yeah you did yeah I dislocated my
shoulder apparently one point in time
and I didn't know I did it I got an MRI
and doctors like you dislocated your
shoulder I'm like a [ __ ] lunatic
I would have been flopping like a fish
out of water if I did it you know who
else broke his neck in a movie Stallone
when he was like 65 and he's doing the
Expendables someone threw him into a
wall and he snapped his neck to this day
he's got bolts and rods and his neck
it's all fused together whoa yeah you
see an x-ray of his neck it's [ __ ]
nuts pull up an x-ray of Sylvester
Stallone's and talk about a guy still
[ __ ] giving people their money's
worth 65 you won't even do this stunt
double this show is like the Sylvester
Stallone fan club show because everybody
like like whenever his name comes up
like the other day Eddie Bravo was
talking about all the [ __ ] movies
it's got the guys relevant from Rocky
one in the 1970s and now he's doing like
Rambo 14 or whatever the [ __ ] it is he's
five years old September 20th yeah he
sent geriatric old man Holden I coming
to get you he's still at it
they're still at billboards everywhere
Rambo people are psyched probably gonna
be the number one movie I love a stunt
man didn't use a stunt man and broke his
[ __ ] neck and then Ancestors out
there any time ago you want the stunt
man to do it always say yes look at this
Tom Cruise delegating himself to the
side of a plane this guys are crazy look
at his neck so he's got a cage scroll up
oh my god yeah so his neck is fused all
those vertebrae and screws and bolts
that nose never come out never
that is his neck for life not only that
it compromises the upper and lower discs
so that when your neck is fused like
that that's an unnatural sort of
condition for those joints so the upper
and lower ones there's there's
additional stress and it's an unnatural
leverage point yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude he did 65s that screws and bolts
his neck and [ __ ] they threw he got
thrown into a wall and crack what does
it say Stone Cold Steve Austin was so
[ __ ] vicious I end up getting a
hairline fracture in my neck I'm not
joking I haven't told anyone this I had
to have a very serious operation
afterwards now I have a metal plate in
my neck yeah yeah Stone Cold Steve
Austin who's you know who's also hit
broke his neck oh you broke everything
all those guys have ever no the guy was
putting him in the piledriver oh really
and he was supposed to but you know
leave distance you're supposed to have
like the guys heads poking through when
he jumps up you kind of ease up with
your legs so at the last second you tuck
your chin I guess right it was how I
watched him explain this [ __ ] and what
the guy guy was like freaking out that
he's fighting him or something like that
or he [ __ ] up oh look you can see it
right there oh yeah see that he just he
he didn't do it properly he dropped him
right on his [ __ ] neck I mean oh this
is almost broken I would have probably
[ __ ] up his disks the craziest what
was crazy was he was supposed to win
that match and then he was just [ __ ]
laying there so they didn't know what to
do so they just took his arm and just
put it on the guy's chest then they were
like one two three over oh my god yeah
the craziest one I ever saw was Brock
Lesnar he did a flip through the air and
landed on his head
flipped through the ice 300 pounds flips
through the air I think he called it a
shooting star press or something that he
would flip through the air to land on
somebody but he miscalculated or he
slipped or whatever when he did the jump
off the top rope Oh God 300-pound
gigantic man lands on his face didn't
even knock him out just continually and
just [ __ ] pinned the guy afterwards
watch this because this [ __ ] oh god
this just freaks me absolutely
preposterous those scroll to the end
where he flies through the air doesn't
they're like just a highlight of the
available we used to joke that that guy
was so big like that's that the sword
tattoo is like actual size yeah it's
right right before that right before
that because that's that's where he's K
out yeah right before that so scroll a
little bit before that a little bit
before that
just right there click there ok so it
must be right before so it seems like
they're showing highlights here ok they
don't have it on YouTube
I think it's cuz he's good at the
animals getting eaten alive yeah this is
it here yes here it is this is him oh no
watch this look at the size of that
[ __ ] it looks like a cartoon it
look boom he missed Oh landed head first
look at him holding his head most humans
are dead right they're just dead oh so
Kurt Angle's trying to pin him nope hugs
him off did the idea that you're even
alive when you land a head like that he
just totally miscalculated he's so lucky
he's not paralyzed oh yeah well he
doesn't have a neck he just has
shoulders that go to the top of his head
and he stays with the storyline huh he
popped out wow that's a [ __ ] pro Wow
so he gets the big bucks yeah he was
thinking about coming back to the UFC up
until just a few months ago he's gonna
fight Daniel Cormier they were holding
the heavyweight title because they were
gonna match matched him and Daniel
Cormier but then he just decided you
know he was doing some legitimate
wrestling with some real national
champions at Michigan State and him you
know I think he got to a point in his
life he's like especially without
steroids because the UFC has very strict
anti-doping policies and the last time
he fought he tested positive and so it
was like look I just can't do this I'm
not gonna do this and plus when he was
on WWE there's not a chance in the world
he was pissing clean I mean so for the
years after the UFC when he was on WWE
he was taking one over the [ __ ] water
- and whose giant built like a [ __ ]
brick [ __ ] and then they're like
he's like I want to fight one more time
and if he's gonna fight one more time
he's got to be clean so he's got to
enter into the you sada testing pool so
he's got to be in that testing pool for
a period of several months before
they'll allow him to compete so they're
testing him this whole time such a dumb
[ __ ] I was picturing him getting into a
pool no and I'm like what do they do
what'd you sweat they figured it out get
in the pool we need to clean you to find
out if you're on steroids but again he
was that close I mean he's like I
so glad you continued to talk to that
point or a little bit I would have drunk
they got a pool and they get in the pool
they make you do some laps in just the
water if there's steroids in it why the
pool I just think it's more accurate
you just keep answering and you don't
have an answer you just give one oh boy
all right so [ __ ] giant human being
you see is that's Viking DNA right there
kids
yeah yes it is all right let's wrap this
[ __ ] up huh
yeah let's get in a sauna relax do it
it's good let's do it a sauna ladies and
gentlemen how did you like this cigar
boy I liked it very much well I didn't
have that one I had this one right here
which was a different one
what is this was this my favorite right
here I wish I could read this but my old
man eyes we're not allow roar a sapphire
great afternoon great afternoon stab it
legs and mild yet flavorful tonight
Netflix midnight midnight all across the
country Eastern Time everywhere midnight
tonight how it works in other countries
but I would think the way Netflix does
their business they're good at it
they're on top of it the [ __ ] yeah
but I'm excited for your brother I'm
very excited to see it too oh thank you
very much and once again thank you to
Mike binder for the way that it looks
shout out to Mike Leinbach and if you
come to the improv and the Comedy Store
Thursday night bill be working with me
we're gonna have some fun and that's it
bye you [ __ ] see you
[Music]